ओके
ओके आई थिंक आई एम लाइव नाउ अ
ओके आई थिंक आई एम लाइव प्लीज लेट मी नो
गाइस इफ आई एम ऑडिबल एंड विज़िबल क्लियरली
एक बार सभी लोग बता दीजिए फटाफट इफ आई एम
ऑडिबल एंड विज़िबल क्लियरली
एवरीवन
अह गुड इवनिंग। गुड इवनिंग। नमस्ते।
नमस्ते टू एवरीबॉडी। नमस्ते। गुड इवनिंग।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ऑडियो वीडियो
सब कुछ सही जा रही है आप लोगों को?
बिल्कुल क्लियर जा रही है।
ओके। ठीक है। इफ एवरीथिंग इज़ क्लियर गुड।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
या नमस्ते गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
या नमस्ते गुड इवनिंग ठीक है
चलिए फिर स्टार्ट करते हैं आज की सेशन
जैसा कि आप सब ने देख ही लिया होगा
जस्ट अ सेकंड
ओके गुड इवनिंग नमस्ते नमस्ते नमस्ते
नमस्ते [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
नमस्ते एवरीबॉडी
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके जस्ट अ सेकंड गाइस अ
आई जस्ट नीड टू डू वन थिंग ओके यस
एक बार आप लोग मुझे सभी लोग एक बार बताइए
फटाफट आप लोगों में से कितने लोगों का
लास्ट सेशन तक कंप्लीट हो चुका है 23 सेशन
तक जो है 23 क्लास तक आपने कर लिया है
कंप्लीट एक बार बताइए फटाफट
एंड लेट मी सेट अप समथिंग फॉर यू। तब तक
मैं आपके लिए कुछ सेटअप भी कर देता हूं।
आज की जो सेशन है वो काफी इंटरेस्टिंग
होने वाली है। लinक्स को हम खत्म करने
वाले हैं गाइस। ठीक है? वी विल बी एंडिंग
द लinक्स।
हो चुकी है। जल्दी से बता दीजिए। फटाफट
बता दीजिए। एवरीबॉडी प्लीज लेट मी नो।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
कंप्लीट। कितने लोगों की हो चुकी है? मतलब
सबकी कहां-कहां कौन-कौन से अभी आप क्लासेस
पे हो? अभी तक अभी आप लोग किन क्लासेस पे
हो? मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए। किन क्लासेस
पर हो अभी आप लोग? कौन से नंबर पर क्लासेस
पर हो जो अभी आप कर रहे हो वह बताओ जल्दी।
मैं जल्दी बता दीजिए।
ओके 21 24 ठीक है।
ओके
24 सर 15 15 ही हुआ है मेरा बिकॉज़ मैं कुछ
ज्यादा ही डीप में पढ़ रहा हूं। एक क्लास
में तीन नहीं लग रहा है। बहुत अच्छी बात
है। इफ समवन इज़ गोइंग इन डीप तो दैट्स
फाइन। दैट्स फाइन। अगर आपको टाइम भी लग
रहा है दैट्स फाइन। टोटली फाइन। उसके
उसमें कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। कई लोग क्या
है देखो आप लोग में से कई लोग जो है जो
सेशन को एसओसी के देख रहे हैं। दो तरह के
यहां पे लोग हैं। मैं आपको बता देता हूं।
एक जो सेशन में जो मैं बता रहा हूं जो मैं
करा रहा हूं उतना कर रहे हैं। दैट्स इट।
खत्म। नोट्स-वोट्स बना रहे हैं। दैट्स इट।
एक ऐसे कुछ ऐसे कैंडिडेट्स हैं। कुछ ऐसे
सेक्शन है आप में से जो सेशन के क्लासेस
को तो अटेंड करते ही हैं। सेशन में जो मैं
बता रहा हूं वो तो करते ही हैं। उसके
अलावा दे आर एक्सप्लोरिंग देमसेल्व्स
आल्सो कि एसओसी लेवल वन एल1 के एसओसी एल1
एनालिस्ट के लिए ये
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] चीजें कितनी
इंपॉर्टेंट है और कितना कुछ और भी कुछ
चीजें चाहिए क्या या थोड़ा मैं खुद से भी
थोड़ा और एक्सप्लोर कर लूं ये बहुत लोग
करते हैं। तो ऐसे लोग जो है ना सेकंड वाले
सेक्शन वाले लोग वो काफी मतलब सही अप्रोच
है उनका एंड यही अप्रोच सबको यूज़ करना
चाहिए अकॉर्डिंग टू मी आप सेम अप्रोच के
साथ ही जाइए प्लीज इट विल बी बेटर फॉर यू
आप यहां जो सीख रहे हैं वो सीखिए साथ में
अपने खुद से भी एक्सप्लोर कीजिए चीजों को
जितना स्कूल में पढ़ाया जा रहा है उतना ही
पढ़ के छोड़ देंगे कुछ नहीं होता है उससे
खुद से जब तक आप एक्सप्लोर नहीं करेंगे यू
विल नॉट गो टू द कोर ऑफ दैट पर्टिकुलर
टॉपिक तो कोर में जाने की कोशिश कीजिए
उसके उसके कोर लेवल तक पहुंचने की कोशिश
कीजिए। डेप्थ तक पहुंचने की कोशिश कीजिए।
वो आपको काफी हेल्प करेगी। बस इतना ही।
ठीक है? आई होप अ आपको समझ में आ गया
होगा।
या सर [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] प्लीज
क्या बोल रहा है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सर प्लीज प्रोवाइड फ्री ट्रेनिंग ऑन
एडब्ल्यूएस सॉल्यूशन आर्किटेक्ट एंड
एडब्ल्यूएस क्लाउड सिक्योरिटी फ्री
ट्रेनिंग ऑन YouTube आफ्टर कंप्लीशन ऑफ़
एसओसी एल1 एडब्ल्यूएस से रिलेटेड ट्रेनिंग
के लिए ट्रेनर लेकर आएंगे हम ट्राई करेंगे
अगर कोई ट्रेनर हमारे पास आता है कोई
ट्रेनर ऐसे करके क्योंकि देखो एडब्ल्यूएस
आर्किटेक्ट की पढ़ाई अगर मुझे करानी होगी
तो मुझे पढ़ के पढ़ाना पड़ेगा आपको
क्योंकि मैं मैंने एडब्ल्यूएस की जो
ट्रेनिंग है वो लेके के नहीं रखी हुई है
ना तो एडब्ल्यूएस से कुछ खास एडब्ल्यूएस
मुझे उतना पता है जितना एक एक नॉर्मल लाइक
एब्ल्यूएस क्लाउड में जो चीजें होती हैं
वो आई नो एवरीथिंग ऑल लॉट ऑफ़ थिंग बट मुझे
नहीं लगता कि आई एम द बेस्ट फिट टू ट्रेन
यू टू द आर्किटेक्ट लेवल जो एडब्ल्यूएस का
जो लेवल होता है दैट नीडेड दैट नीडेड अ
प्रोफेशनल एंड उसके लिए अगर कोई मिलता है
देन आई विल बी डेफिनेटली स्टार्टिंग दैट
एंड अगर मैंने खुद नहीं कर लिया तो मैं
मैं खुद ही करा दूंगा आपके। राइट? तो
लेट्स सी हाउ इज़ दैट गोइंग। अगर कोई और
टॉपिक भी है तो हम उसको देखेंगे। उसको वी
विल बी सीइंग लाइक हाउ वी कैन गो विथ दैट।
ठीक है? हम उसको भी देख लेंगे। टॉपिक्स के
लिए दिक्कत नहीं है। वी विल ट्राई टू
ब्रिंग अ लॉट ऑफ़ डिफरेंट टॉपिक्स फॉर यू।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है।
आई एम कौन सा सर्टिफाइड सर? सर वाज़
सर्चिंग फॉर एसओसी फाउंड दिस ट्रेनिंग
ट्रेजर फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट लव एंड रिस्पेक्ट
फ्रॉम पाकिस्तान। चलिए अच्छी बात है। आपको
अच्छा लग रहा है यह ट्रेनिंग दैट्स गुड।
आई एम आई एम आल्सो वेरी हैप्पी दैट यू
गाइस आर लर्निंग फ्रॉम दिस। आप पाकिस्तान
से हैं और अगर आप सीख पा रहे हैं इस
ट्रेनिंग से भी तो दैट्स फाइन। क्योंकि
YouTube को तो क्या ही रोक सकते हैं। बट
ठीक है। चलो अच्छी बात है। आप सीखते रहिए,
मस्त रहिए।
जितना सीख सके उतना सीखिए। दैट वुड बी
फाइन। ठीक है?
है भाई हिमांशु बिल्कुल है डीडीएफएस की
क्लास ऑलरेडी ऑनगोइंग है। चलिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
आज हम एसओसी में लinक्स का खात्मा करने
वाले हैं गाइस। काली लinक्स आपके सामने
दिख रहा होगा। वी विल बी एंडिंग द लinक्स
पार्ट। लinक्स हम पार्ट कंप्लीट करेंगे।
यानी एसओसी का बेसिक्स कंप्लीट कर लिया
हमने। हमने एसओसी में साइबर सिक्योरिटी
पार्ट कंप्लीट किया। नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी
पार्ट कंप्लीट किया। ओ ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
में Windows कंप्लीट किया। आज लिनिक्स
कंप्लीट हो जाएगा। इसके बाद आज के क्लास
के बाद आपका जो है वो
एसओसी की मोस्टली सेशंस जो होंगी जो
एक्चुअल एसओसी की ट्रायग
टीम होती है या अलर्ट अलर्ट के लिए जिस
तरीके से आपको चीजें सीखनी है। कैसे आप
ट्राई करते हैं, कैसे अलर्ट करेंगे, किस
तरीके से एस्केलेट करेंगे, किस तरीके से
एसआईएम डैशबोर्ड को यूज़ करेंगे, ये सारी
चीजें हम देखेंगे। प्रैक्टिकल
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन, प्रैक्टिकल थिंग्स जो है
वो ज्यादातर मोस्टली आपके
मतलब इस क्लास के बाद आपके होने वाली है।
तो आपको मजा आएगा। काफी ज्यादा मजा आएगा
आई थिंक। तो यू विल बी एंजॉयंग द सेशंस। अ
एंड आज के भी सेशन को आप एंजॉय तो करोगे
बट इसके बाद वाले जो सेशंस होंगे वो आपको
जैसे बहुत लोग बोल रहे थे सर प्रैक्टिकल
लेकर आओ। प्रैक्टिकल लेकर नहीं आए। ये वो
तो उसके लिए मैंने ये चीज़ आपको बता मैं
आपको ये चीज़ बता रहा हूं। राइट। तो सबसे
पहला जो काम आपको करना है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
सर आप आरसीबी के फैन नहीं हो। मैं किसी का
फैन नहीं हूं भाई क्योंकि मैं देखता ही
नहीं हूं यार। मैं जो तुम बोल रहे हो
आईपीएल वगैरह वो मैं देखता नहीं हूं। जब
हां कभी कभी मैच हुआ कभी कोहली, धोनी
वगैरह की टीम की तो कभी थोड़ी बहुत देख
ली। बट वैसे मैं नहीं देखता। आई एम नॉट
लाइक वेरी मच फॉन्टों ऑफ़ दैट। ओके।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। सो यहां पे अब जो है
नाउ वी आर सबसे पहले आपको डिफ्रॉनिक्स
एकडमी YouTube चैनल ओपन कर लेना है। लाइव
सेक्शन में आपको आ जाना है। लाइव सेक्शन
में किसी भी एसओसी की प्रीवियस क्लास पे
आप आ जाइएगा। यहां डिस्क्रिप्शन को
एक्सपेंड करके दो लिंक्स आपको मिलेंगे। एक
आपको मिलेगा WhatsApp चैनल का डिफ्रॉनिक्स
एकडमी नाम से। आप इसको WhatsApp चैनल पे
जाके WhatsApp पे एक्सप्लोर चैनल्स पे
जाके सर्च करेंगे तब भी आपको मिल जाएगा।
इस चैनल को बिल्कुल फॉलो कर लीजिएगा
क्योंकि डिफ्रॉनिक्स के साइट से कुछ भी
अपडेट जो आती है सबसे पहले आपको इसी चैनल
पे आती है। ओवरऑल सारी अपडेट जो आती हैं
सब में सबसे पहले डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी
YouTube WhatsApp चैनल के ऊपर आपको मिलती
है जहां 13000 लोग हमसे जुड़े हैं अभी तक
और एक ग्रुप आपको मिलेगा एसओसी का स्पेशल
ग्रुप जो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] कि
आपको स्पेसिफिक टू दिस पर्टिकुलर ट्रेनिंग
है एंड जितने भी नोट्स हैं रिसोर्सेज हैं
इस ट्रेनिंग के इस ट्रेनिंग के अपडेट्स
हैं इस ट्रेनिंग की फ्यूचर जो अपडेट्स
होंगी जो आने वाली आपके जॉब रेडी क्योंकि
ये जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग में मैंने आपको
बुलाया था बोला था आपको एक इंटरव्यू टाइप
सिनेरियो भी आपको प्रोवाइड करूंगा। एक एक
किस तरीके से आपको इंटरव्यू वगैरह क्रैक
करने हैं। कैसे आपको क्वेश्चंस वगैरह और
बहुत सारी चीजें जो भी इनेशन होंगी वो सब
आपको इन्हीं ग्रुप्स में मिला करेंगी। तो
इनको जरूर जॉइ कर लीजिएगा। साथ ही में अगर
आपको नहीं पता Lindin पे मैं प्रेजेंट
हूं। अगर आप Lindin पे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] मुझसे कनेक्ट
होना चाहते हैं तो आप Lindin पे जा सकते
हैं। यह यूजर हैंडल है। आप इस पे मुझसे
कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं Lindin के ऊपर में।
यहां कनेक्ट हो के आप मुझसे बातें कर सकते
हैं। मुझ या फिर आप चाहे तो फॉलो कर सकते
हैं मेरे काम को। यहां पे लगभग 13,000 लोग
हमसे जुड़े हुए हैं। तो आप भी आके कनेक्ट
हो सकते हैं। इट्स टोटली अप टू यू। Lindin
पे ही आप डिफ़्रॉनिक सर्च करेंगे तो आपको
हमारी जो कंपनी है डिफ़्रॉनिक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी उसकी Lindin पेज आपको देखने को
मिलेगी। उस Lindin पेज पे आप जाके हमारी
कंपनी के रिगार्डिंग जो अभी अपडेट्स होंगे
या लाइक व्हाटएवर लाइक कंपनी हमारी किस
तरीके से क्या-क्या चीजें कर रही हैं, आगे
क्या-क्या परफॉर्म करने वाली हैं। बीइंग
एन स्टार्टअप किस तरीके से हम स्केल कर
रहे हैं, क्या-क्या चीजें ला रहे हैं। ये
सारी चीजें जो है आपको इस Lindin पेज पे
मिल जाएंगी। यह यहां पे लोडिंग इशू आ रहा
है। कुछ मे बी सम इशज़ आर देयर। सो इसको हम
रीलोड करके एक बार देख लेते हैं। इफ देयर
इज़ समथिंग अ
तो आप उस Lindin पेज को विजिट कर सकते
हैं। आई थिंक देयर इज़ सम इशू। तो मैं इसको
बैक करके मैं यहां से डायरेक्ट ओपन करके
आपको दिखाता हूं। आप वैसे डिफ़्रॉनिक सर्च
करेंगे यू विल गेट द Lindin पेज ऑफ़
डिफ़्रॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी। सो देयर आर
सम Lindin साइड इशू आई थिंक सो। तो यहां
पे यह पेज आ गया है। यहां पे भी लगभग
22,000 लोग हमसे जुड़े हुए हैं। एंड हियर
यू कैन सी द थिंग। हां, यहां पर अभी
रिसेंटली मैंने गिव अवे के विनर्स को
अनाउंस किया है। इनको बहुत जल्द यह विनर्स
में जो जो इनके नाम है यह अभी जो हमारे
50000 सब्सक्राइबर के एक एक खुशी एक
हैप्पी मोमेंट पे गिव अवे अनाउंस किया था
मैंने। आप सबको शायद पता होगा। तो उनके
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] विनर्स की लिस्ट
आ चुकी है जिसमें डीसीएपीटी हमारी
ट्रेनिंग जो है उसमें तीन विनर्स हमने
सेलेक्ट किए थे और एक ट्राईकमी वन ईयर का
एक्सेस के लिए हमने सेलेक्ट किया था और एक
बोनस वन मंथ ट्राईकमी वाउचर के लिए एक
कैंडिडेट को हमने सेलेक्ट किया था एंड द
लिस्ट्स आर हियर सो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
उसके बाद गाइज़ यहां पे आप सभी को अ एक्स
के पेज पे जाना है डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी को
इसको फॉलो फॉलो कर लेना है। यह हमारा एक्स
का पेज है यानी Twitter का पेज है। आप इस
पे आके हमारे डिफ़्रॉनिक्स के साइबर
सिक्योरिटी डिफ़ॉन साइबर सिक्योरिटी पेज को
फॉलो कर सकते हैं। साथ ही में गाइज़
Instagram पे मैं अवेलेबल हूं। आप
Instagram पे चाहें तो मुझसे कनेक्ट हो
सकते हैं। मुझे फॉलो कर सकते हैं। सो दिस
इज़ द हैंडल। Instagram नितेश सिंह हैकर
करके एक हैंडल मिलेगा आपको। यहां पे आप
मेरी डेली लाइफ, मेरी पर्सनल लाइफ इन सब
से जुड़ सकते हैं। और यह हमारे
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी का Instagram हैंडल है।
जहां पे हमारे डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एकडमी के
Instagram हैंडल को फॉलो करके आप हमारे इस
पेज से भी जुड़ सकते हैं। फॉर वेरियस
इनेशनल एंड लाइक रील कंटेंट्स एंड ऑल सब
कुछ। तो, यह सोशल हैंडल्स हैं। यह हमारी
वेबसाइट है जो अभी रिवैंप होने वाली है।
कंप्लीट न्यू लुक न्यू डिज़ाइन में आने
वाली है। बहुत जल्द आपको देखने को मिल
जाएगी। फिलहाल के लिए यह है। आप इस पे
विजिट करके डिटेल्स चेक आउट कर सकते हैं।
एकडमी पे जाके हमारे द्वारा प्रोवाइडेड जो
कोर्सेज हैं उन कोर्सेज को आप एक्सप्लोर
कर सकते हैं। ये सारी चीजें तो हो गई। जान
पहचान हो गई हमारी। जिनको नहीं पता था
उनके लिए स्पेशली। अब यहां पे हम आज की जो
सेशन है उसको शुरू करेंगे। तो आज के सेशन
को शुरू तो करेंगे बट आज का सेशन बहुत ही
बहुत ही ज्यादा कमाल का होने वाला है और
दी एंड होने वाला है आपके लinिक्स वाले
पार्ट का। Linx पार्ट से आप सब काफी
ज्यादा आई थिंक परेशान हो गए थे। बट Linux
इज रियली रियली अमेजिंग। अगर आपको मैं सच
बताऊं एंड यू शुड नॉट गेट बोर्ड ऑफ़ इट।
Linx ही आपका फ्यूचर है। Linux ही सब कुछ
है। सर्वर्स में Linux है। क्लाइंट साइड
भी Linux है। हर जगह Linux है। Linux की
जितनी सफिशिएंट एक कर्नल और या Linux
बेस्ड ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इनके कंपैरिजन में
कोई सा भी मशीन कुछ खास काम करता नहीं है।
एंड Mac OS भी आपका उसी का पार्ट है। अगर
आप सोच रहे हैं कि Mac OS क्या है? MacB
उसी का है। एक तरह से आप बोल सकते हैं
Linux बेस्ड डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन यू कैन से।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चलिए अब यहां पे Linx कर्नल यूज़ होती है।
बहुत सारे ऐसे डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन या बहुत
सारे मशीनंस है उसमें। दैट्स इट। तो यहां
पे या गौरव जांगरा बहुत अच्छी बात है। हां
जी। इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस के भी टॉपिक्स हैं
इसमें।
इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस के भी टॉपिक्स हैं।
कोई बेस्ट लinक्स बताओ ना डायरेक्ट यूज़ के
लिए। U1 यूज़ कर लो। उबू
[खांसने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सर, मेरा भी
12th क्लास पे हूं। डिटेल में नोट्स बना
रहा हूं। टाइम लग रहा है। एग्जाम्स भी थी
मेरी। हां, अच्छी बात है रुद्र। इफ यू आर
ऑन 12th क्लास एंड आप डिटेल में सब कुछ कर
रहे हो। दैट्स टोटली फाइन।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
चलिए तो आज की जो सेशन है उसको हम शुरू
करेंगे क्रोन टैब से। Linx के अंदर देयर
इज़ अ क्रोन टैब थिंग क्रोन टैब। तो हम उस
क्रोन टैब से शुरू करने वाले हैं आज के
सेशन को। एंड आई होप कि आपको ये चीजें जो
है वो बहुत बहुत ज्यादा क्लियर हो जाएंगी।
क्रron टैब और यह सब चीजें जब आप बेसिकली
जब आप मतलब मैं आपको बताता हूं Linux में
Chron टैब कुछ वैसा ही है अ जैसा
जैसा आपका शेड्यूलर होता है। Windows के
अंदर में जो टास्क शेड्यूलर होते हैं,
वैसे ही Linux में आपका क्रोन टैब है। ये
क्या करता है ना? आपके टास्क को शेड्यूल
कर देता है। ठीक है? एक फिक्स टाइम पे
शेड्यूल करके। जैसे आप अपने रील्स वगैरह
पोस्ट करते हो शेड्यूल करके। कोई भी ऐसे
कुछ भी लाइक शेड्यूलिंग का काम होता है वो
क्रैब से होता है Linux के अंदर में। अब
ये कितना इंपॉर्टेंट है मैं आपको बता देता
हूं। एक पर्टिकुलर डेट पे एक पर्टिकुलर डे
पे एक पर्टिकुलर मंथ में एक पर्टिकुलर
पर्टिकुलर डेट एक पर्टिकुलर डेट पर्टिकुलर
टाइम के बाद कोई इवेंट ऑटोमेटिकली अकर
करे। कोई इवेंट ऑटोमेटिकली क्या करे? वो
एग्जीक्यूट हो जाए। सो इसको हम क्रोन टैब
के थ्रू करते हैं। Linux के अंदर में
मोटा-मोटी अभी अभी ये समझ लीजिए सिंपल सी
लैंग्वेज में। अब इसका सबसे बड़ा एक देखो
ये दो तरह की चीजें एक प्रॉफिट मतलब एक
बेनिफिट बेनिफिट भी आपके लिए आपके लिए
बेनिफिशियल भी है और आपके लिए यह
प्रॉब्लमैटिक भी है। बेनिफिशियल क्या कि
आपके काम को इजी बनाता है। आपके काम को
लाइक बहुत ही एक फिक्स टाइम पे एक फिक्स
डे डेट में आपके अह टास्क को एग्जीक्यूट
करता है। प्रॉब्लमेटिक है कि हैकर्स इसका
यूज़ पर्सिस्टेंस लेने के लिए कर सकते हैं
कि एक पर्टिकुलर टाइम पे एक पर्टिकुलर डे
पे एक एक्सप्लइट जो है वो बार-बार
एग्जीक्यूट हो रहा हो। एक मैलवेयर जो है
वो बार-बार एग्जीक्यूट हो रहा है। तो ये
प्रॉब्लमेटिक चीज है जो कि क्रोन टैब के
थ्रू होती है। अब इसका
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] बहुत बड़ा
रोल है अ इन एज एन एसओसी अगर आप एक एसओसी
एनालिस्ट हैं तो आपके लिए ये काफी ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट हो जाता है। देखो
लinx [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] में क्रोन
टैब जो है एक टास्क शेड्यूलर है। रन
कमांड्स ऑटोमेटिकली एट शेड्यूल टाइम्स। तो
यह कमांड्स और स्क्रिप्ट्स को रन करता है
एक शेड्यूल टाइम पे। ठीक है? कोई भी
शेड्यूल टाइम वो शेड्यूल आप फिक्स करेंगे
एंड उस पे ये क्या करता है? रन करता है
कमांड्स को। ठीक है? इन द वर्ल्ड ऑफ़
लinक्स क्रोन इज़ द अलार्म क्लॉक ऑफ़ द
सिस्टम। ये एक अलार्म क्लॉक है। जैसे आप
अलार्म लगाते हो 10:00 बजे की, 11:00 बजे
की, 12:00 बजे की, 2:00 बजे की, 3:00 बजे
की। वैसे ही यह टाइम के अकॉर्डिंग सेट
करता है सब कुछ। इट इज़ अ टाइम बेस्ड जॉब
शेड्यूलर दैट अलाउ यू टू रन स्क्रिप्ट्स
और कमांड्स ऑटोमेटिकली एट स्पेसिफिक
इंटरवल्स।
तो, यह क्या है? ये टाइम बेस्ड जॉब
शेड्यूलर है। टाइम बेस्ड है। ठीक है? जो
कि किसी भी तरह के स्क्रिप्ट्स या क्या
करता है? कमांड्स को चलाता है एक
स्पेसिफिक इंटरवल पे। फॉर एसओसी
एक एसओसी एनालिस्ट के लिए क्रॉन इज अ डबल
एज स्वॉर्ड। मतलब दो धारी तलवार है यह।
डबल एज स्वॉर्ड का मतलब होता है दो धारी
तलवार। इट्स एन एसेंशियल टूल फॉर ऑटोमेशन।
ऑटोमेशन के लिए बहुत एसेंशियल है। एंड
हेल्थ मॉनिटरिंग हेल्थ मॉनिटरिंग के लिए।
बट इट्स आल्सो वन ऑफ़ द मोस्ट कॉमन प्लेसेस
फॉर अटैकर्स टू हाइड पर्सिस्टेंस
मैकेनिज्म। अटैकर्स के लिए ये सबसे कॉमन
प्लेस है अपने पर्सिस्टेंस मैकेनिज्म को
हाइड करने के लिए। जैसा मैंने बताया कि
पर्सिस्टेंस मतलब एक टाइम के बाद एक फिक्स
टाइम के बाद बार-बार कोई चीज को चलाना।
कोई मैलवेयर को एग्जीक्यूट करा देना। कोई
एक्सप्लइट है उसको एग्जीक्यूट करा देना।
किस तो देयर कैन बी अ डिफरेंट थिंग्स
राइट? दैट कैन बी डन। तो, यह बहुत डेंजरस
भी हो सकता है। अब देखो, Linux में टास्क
टास्क शेड्यूलिंग कैसे काम करती है? मैं
आपको सिंपल सा एक तरीका बता देता हूं। एक
वन टाइम एग्जीक्यूशन होता है, एक रिकरिंग
एग्जीक्यूशन होता है। वन टाइम एग्जीक्यूशन
तो आप कमांड देके चला देते हो। अब जैसे
मान लो कोई भी कमांड कोई भी टास्क ही तो
हो रहा है। जैसे मैं ये लinक्स ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम मैंने ओपन कर ली। राइट? अब मैं
यहां पे टर्मिनल ओपन कर लेता हूं। राइट?
अब टर्मिनल मैंने ओपन किया। अब मैं यहां
पे क्या कर रहा हूं? मैं एक कमांड चला दे
रहा हूं। कैल एंटर किया। कैलेंडर ओपन हो
गया। अब मैंने इस कमांड को टाइप करके एंटर
किया तभी तो कैलेंडर ओपन हुई। राइट?
कैलेंडर हैज़ बीन ओपन। तो यह भी तो एक
इवेंट ही हो रहा है। ये भी तो एक काम ही
हो रहा है। ये भी तो एक टास्क ही हो रहा
है। तो मैंने कमांड चलाया तब ये टास्क
हुआ। तो ये वन टाइम वाला चीज हो गया। तो
ये द सेम थिंग इज़ देयर वन टाइम
एग्जीक्यूशन। तो ये वन टाइम होगा। जब आप
कमांड टाइप करोगे वन टाइम हो जाएगा। ठीक
है? तो नो सपोर्ट फॉर रेकरिंग टास्क।
रेकरिंग टास्क के लिए इसमें कोई सपोर्ट
नहीं होता है। यह इसका लिमिटेशन है कि कोई
भी रेकरिंग टास्क आप इसमें इसके थ्रू नहीं
कर सकते। ऑब्वियस सी बात है। बट अगर वही
कैल कमांड या डेट कमांड या कोई सा भी
कमांड आपको हर कुछ-कुछ देर पे चलानी है तो
उसके लिए आता है रिकरिंग एग्जीक्यूशन वाला
तरीका जिसमें हम क्रॉन को यूज़ करते हैं।
क्रॉन टैब को यानी क्रोन टेबल होती है। वो
क्रॉन टैब इज़ क्रोन टेबल। दैट्स इट। क्रॉन
टैब स्टैंड्स फॉर क्रॉन टेबल। टेबल तो ये
क्रॉन के थ्रू होता है। अब इसमें भी दो
तरीके की चीजें होती है। हैंडल्स मिस
जॉब्स और एक फेल्स इफ सिस्टम इज ऑफ। इसका
एक लिमिटेशन है सिस्टम ऑफ है तो यह फेल हो
जाएगा। अगर सिस्टम आपका बंद है तो यह काम
नहीं करता है। लेकिन सिस्टम ऑन है तब यह
काम बिल्कुल करेगा। एंड हैंडल्स मिस्ड
जॉब्स। मतलब कोई एक मिस्ड कोई मिस्ड हो
गया है। कोई जॉब, कोई टास्क मिस हो गई है
तो उसको भी यह हैंडल करता है एनाक्रॉन के
थ्रू। एनाक्रॉन भी एक यूटिलिटी है जो कि
यूज़ में ली जाती है जो भी मिस जॉब्स है
उसको हैंडल करने के लिए। अब इसमें एक
लिमिटेशन ये है कि इसको रूट प्रिविलेज
चाहिए तभी यह काम करेगा। बिना रूट के यह
काम जनरली नहीं करेगा। यानी रूट की
प्रिविलेज चाहिए। रूट वाला यूजर ही इसको
एग्जीक्यूट कर पाएगा। ये थोड़ी सी इसकी
लिमिटेशन है। यानी कि अगर कोई नॉर्मल यूजर
चाहे एनाक्रॉन को यूज़ करने का तो वो शायद
ना कर पाए। मतलब उसको यह लिमिटेशन है। तो
वो पॉसिबल नहीं हो पाएगी। बट अगर नॉर्मल
रूट यूजर है, रूट से लॉग इन है तो ये सारी
चीजें आराम से हो सकती हैं। तो ये टू दो
तरीके से होती हैं। एक वन टाइम और एक
रिकरिंग होता है जिसमें क्रॉन का ये
रेकरिंग में बस इतना याद रखना है आपको
ध्यान रखना है कि रेकरिंग में क्रॉन का
यूज़ होता है। एक एनाक्रॉन होता है जो
मिस्ड जो भी एग्जीक्यूशन होती है या जॉब्स
होती है, टास्क होती है उसको हैंडल वो
करता है। बस ये दो टर्म्स क्रॉन एंड
एनाक्रॉन आपको याद रखना है। बाकी सब भूल
जाइए। क्रॉन टैब आपको याद रखना है क्योंकि
क्रोन टैब ही कम कमांड होती है। ठीक है?
दैट्स इट।
ओके [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सर आज कितने घंटे का सेशन है? अब ये मैं
कैसे पहले ही बता दूं यार अगर तुम्हें
ज्यादा लगे तो तुम जब चाहे तब सेशन लीव कर
सकते हो। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। बट जब तक
मैं करा रहा हूं तब तक आपको पढ़ना है।
दैट्स इट। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब देखिए
नेक्स्ट पे क्लिक करते हैं। अब यहां पे
Linux cront टैब के बारे में थोड़ा सा
हमें जानना है कि एग्जैक्टली ये होता क्या
है? किस तरीके से काम करता है? ठीक है?
देखो, द क्रॉन टैब जिसको हम बोलते हैं
क्रोन टेबल इज़ द कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल वेयर यू
डिफाइन योर शेड्यूल्स। ये एक कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
फाइल है Linux में। मैंने बोला था ना
Linux के अंदर में एवरीथिंग इज़ अ फाइल।
एवरीथिंग कमांड चलाते हैं वो भी फाइल है।
फाइल बनाते हैं वो भी फाइल है। डायरेक्टरी
जो बना रहे हैं वो भी फाइल है। सब फाइल
है। ईच लाइन इन अ क्रोन टैब फॉलोज़ अ
स्पेसिफिक फाइव फील्ड सिंटेक्स
रिप्रेजेंट रिप्रेजेंटिंग टाइम फॉललोड बाय
द कमांड टू एग्जीक्यूट। तो यह एक
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल है जिसके अंदर में ठीक
है? पांच फील्ड की सिंटेक्स वाली एक लाइन
होती है।
ठीक? पांच फील्ड वाली जिसमें कि
पांच जो शुरू के फील्ड्स होते हैं वो टाइम
को बताते हैं। डेट एंड टाइम। एंड जो लास्ट
वाला फील्ड होता है वह बताता है कि कौन से
कमांड को एग्जीक्यूट करना है या कौन से
स्क्रिप्ट को चलाना है। उसका वह पाथ होता
है। अब इसको हम सामने देखते हैं। राइट?
[खांसने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
इसको वी विल बी सीइंग इन फ्रंट ऑफ़ आर्स।
अब यहां पे यह सामने आप दिख रहा है। डे
मैं यहां पे टर्मिनल ओपन करके बैठा हूं।
Linux के अंदर में खाली है। यहां पे यूज़
कर रहा हूं। तो क्रron टैब की कॉन्फ़िगरेशन
फाइल को एडिट करने के लिए यू नीड टू टाइप
अ कमांड नेम क्रron टैब हफन ई ये कमांड
आपको चलाना पड़ेगा। क्रron टैब हफन ई
हफन ई
क्रॉन टैब hन ई ये कमांड आपको चलाना है।
यह कमांड जब चलाएंगे तो आप एंटर करेंगे तो
एंटर जब करेंगे तो कुछ इस तरीके से आपको
यहां पर देखने को मिलेगी। यह जो फाइल है
यह देखने को इस तरीके से मिलेगी। इसमें यह
एंट्री नहीं होगी। इस तरीके से कुछ देखने
को आपको यह फाइल मिलेगी। यह क्रोन टैब की
क्या है? कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल है। क्रोन की
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल है। इसी के अंदर में आप
डिफरेंट टाइप ऑफ चेंजेस कर सकते हैं और
अपनी क्रोन जॉब को सेटअप कर सकते हैं। ठीक
है? अब इसमें जब आप आएंगे तो आपको यहां पे
दिखेगा। यू विल सी
यहां पे यह आप देख सकते हैं। यह आपको दिख
रहा होगा। ये कुछ इस तरीके का सिंटेक्स
यहां पे मेंशंड है। पहले यहां पे एम है।
फिर एच है, डी ओ एम है, एम ओ एन है, डी ओ
डब्ल्यू है, कमांड है। एम का मतलब है
मिनट। एच का मतलब है आर। डे ये डी ओ एम का
मतलब है जो डे ऑफ़ मंथ है। एम ओ एन मतलब
मंथ। डी ओ डब्ल्यू मतलब डे ऑफ़ वीक। तो ये
सारी चीजें मेंशन करनी पड़ती है। एंड देन
लास्ट में जो कमांड है या फिर कमांड हो या
फिर कोई स्क्रिप्ट हो जो भी है उसकी पूरी
पाथ आपको देनी पड़ती है। कुछ इस तरीके से
यह काम करता है आपका। ठीक है? तो इस तरीके
से अब देखिए यहां पे ये तो आपको दिख गया
काम करता है। इसी चीज को मैंने यहां पे
आपको सामने बताया हुआ है जो यह मंथ, डेट
यह सारी चीजें हैं। यह मैंने आपको यहां पे
बताया हुआ है कि कुछ इस तरीके के सिंटेक्स
होती है। यहां पे शुरू के पांच जो फील्ड्स
होते हैं वो डेट एंड टाइम के होते हैं और
लास्ट में कमांड के एग्जीक्यूट का होता है
जो आपने यहां पे फिलहाल देख लिया है। अब
इसमें जो पहला फील्ड होता है वो होता है
मिनट का। द फर्स्ट फील्ड इज द मिनट फील्ड
जिसमें आप मिनट बताते हो जीरो से 59 तक
क्योंकि मिनट 60 मिनट तक जो होते हैं वही
होते हैं। तो ये मिनट बता द एग्जैक्ट मिनट
द टास्क स्टार्ट्स। एग्जैक्ट मिनट जब
टास्क ये स्टार्ट होगा। उसके बाद दूसरा
फील्ड होता है आर का जो कि 0 से 23 आर
होता है जो कि 24 आर फॉर्मेट में होता है।
24 आवर फॉर्मेट का मतलब है वही 13 का मतलब
1:00 बज रहे हैं। 14 का मतलब 2:00 बज रहे
हैं। 18 का मतलब 6:00 बज रहे हैं। वो वाली
फॉर्मेट यहां पे एएमपीएम का फॉर्मेट नहीं
है। 24 आवर फॉर्मेट है। तो ज़ीरो से लेके
23 तक यहां पे ये होता है। जिसमें 0 12 को
आप बोल रहे हैं एंड बाकी 1 2 3 4 जैसे
होता है वैसे आपका ये फॉलो होगा। तो इस
तरीके से यह सेकंड फील्ड होता है जो कि
आपका आर का होता है। उसके बाद होता है डे
ऑफ मंथ। यह थर्ड फील्ड है। डे ऑफ मंथ। दिस
इज द थर्ड फील्ड। डे ऑफ मंथ जिसमें कि मंथ
की डे होती है। कौन सा डे है भाई? तो
फर्स्ट, सेकंड, थर्ड, फोर्थ यानी जो डे
मतलब डेट होती है 1 2 3 4 5 31 तक होता है
जनरली। अब किसी मंथ में 28 होते हैं फरवरी
में। किसी में 29 भी होते हैं। किसी में
30 होता है, किसी में 31 होता है। तो ये
31 तक कैलेंडर डे जो होता है वो होता है।
फोर्थ जो फील्ड होता है आपका ये चौथा जो
फील्ड है वो होता है वन टू 12। क्या होता
है? मंथ। कौन सा मंथ है? तो 12 महीने होते
हैं तो 12 तक होता है ये। तो वन टू 12।
फर्स्ट इज़ जनवरी, 12 इज़ दिसंबर। उसके बाद
लास्ट जो फील्ड होती है वो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] होती है डे ऑफ़
वीक। वीक का कौन सा दिन है? कौन सा डे है?
तो 0 से सिक्स होता है। 0 मतलब वीक में
कौन सा दिन है? तो 0 से सिक्स में जीरो
संडे होता है और सिक्स सैटरडे होता है। तो
जीरो संडे हो गया। वन आपका मंडे टू
ट्यूसडे थ्री वेडनेसडे ऐसे करके सिक्स
सैटरडे फिर आपका ज़ीरो संडे। तो इस तरीके
से ये डिवाइडेड होती है। इसी तरीके से
आपको सेटअप करना होता है। एज एन एसओसी एल1
क्रॉन इज़ वेरीेंट फॉर यू।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यू यू विल बी यूजिंग दिस क्रोन
फ्रीक्वेंटली एज एन एसओसीएल वन। आपको ये
यूज़ करना ही पड़ेगा। एंड ये काफी आपके काम
आता है। तो इसको आप समझिएगा थोड़ा सा।
बीइंग एन अगर आप एसओसी में जाना चाहते हैं
तो बिल्कुल समझिएगा। तो ये जो आपको मैंने
फॉर्मेट बताया यही फॉर्मेट जो है वो यहां
पे इस कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल में भी मेंशंड है।
देखो आप यहां पे एम ये सेम फॉर्मेट है।
वहां मैंने बताया आपको पांच फील्ड्स थे।
यहां भी पांच शुरू के पांच है। 1 2 3 4 5
और लास्ट का कमांड वाला एक छह टोटल
फील्ड्स हैं जिसमें पांच डेट एंड टाइम को
बताते हैं। छठा जो है आपका वो आपका
एग्जैक्ट जो कमांड है जिसको आपको रन करना
है एक स्पेसिफिक डेट टाइम पे जो आप मेंशन
करेंगे शुरू के पांच फील्ड्स में वो आपका
है। तो आपका ये यहां तक क्लियर आपको समझ
में आया कि एग्जैक्टली क्रोन ये
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल कहां से आई है भैया? ये
कौन सॉरी ये कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल कहां से आई
है? तो मैंने कमांड चलाया क्रron टैब hfन
ई ये किसी भी लinक्स डिजिट में चलाएंगे आप
तो यह वाला कमांड चल के आपको आ जाएगा इसकी
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल क्रॉन टैब hन ई तो आप
एडिट कर पाएंगे इसकी कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल को
यहां पे कुछ इस तरीके से आप देख सकते हैं।
यहां पे मैंने एक सैंपल आपको डाला भी है
कि मान लो कि 1 मिनट पे अ ये ये डेट कमांड
चलानी है तो इसे इस तरीके से आप चला सकते
हैं। याद रखिएगा मान लो अगर आपको डेट
कमांड चलानी है एक स्पेसिफिक इंटरवल पे तो
आप उसका टाइम वहीम आवर वगैरह जो भी है वो
सब मेंशन कर दीजिए एंड लास्ट में उस डेट
का डेट कमांड का पाथ डाल दीजिए। अब यहां
पे जरूरी ये है कि आपको डेट कमांड की पाथ
डालनी है। याद रखिएगा दिस दिस शुड बी द
पाथ। सिर्फ डेट कमांड नहीं लिख देना है।
डेट कमांड एग्जैक्टली कहां पे रहती है वो
पाथ देना है। तो अब मुझे अगर पाथ देखना है
डेट कमांड की तो व्हिच कमांड आई विल इशू?
बताइए मुझे आप में से किसी को अगर पता हो
अगर मुझे डेट कमांड का यह पाथ देखना है जो
कि यूएसआर स यूएसआर के अंदर बिन के अंदर
डेट है इसको मैं कैसे देखूंगा टर्मिनल पे
किसी को पता है इसके बारे में
फिलहाल मैं यहां से बाहर निकल जाता हूं
और [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] मुझे अगर डेट
कमांड की पाथ देखनी है पीडब्ल्यूडी वाह
क्या यार
कुछ भी बोल रहे हो पीडब्ल्यूडी से डेट
कमांड की पाथ दिख जाएगी तो प्रेजेंट
वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी दिखती है। एक किसी ने
बोला वि डेट। सो वी विल टाइप वि एंड डेट
एंड इट विल शो यू द एग्जैक्ट पाथ द डेट
कमांड या डेट बाइनरी बिलोंग्स टू। ठीक है?
सो जिन्होंने विच बोला सबसे पहले मिस्टर
रोबोट हैं। उन्होंने बोला उसके बाद या
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] उनका बिल्कुल
सही है। सिर्फ उन्हीं का सही है। बाकी
लोगों का गलत है। ठीक है? ओके। एक ने बोला
फाइंड डेट। देखो फाइंड डेट जब करोगे यहां
पे तो यहां पे कुछ भी नहीं आएगा क्योंकि
फाइंड का एक अपना सिंटेक्स होता है। एक
अपना तरीका होता है फाइंड कमांड का। फाइंड
से भी आप वैसे तो निकाल सकते हो बट इसका
एक सिंटेक्स होता है। तभी आपको तभी आपको
डेट का वो निकलेगा। ऐसे फाइंड डेट से नहीं
होता है। लेकिन विच से आप आराम से कर सकते
हो। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। कोई इशू नहीं
है। ठीक है? वो आपका निकल के आ जाएगा। ठीक
है? हां। व्हिच डेट इज़ गुड। हां लोकेट।
यस। अगर आप लोकेट कमांड एंड डेट करते हैं
तो इससे होगा क्या कि डेट डेट जो कीवर्ड
है उससे रिलेटेड जितने भी आउटपुट्स हैं वो
सब आपको यहां पे देखने को मिल जाएंगे।
टोटल सारी चीजें लोकेट में आपको सारी
चीजें मिल जाती हैं। तो इसमें एक यही
थोड़ी सी गड़बड़ है कि लोकेट जब आप करोगे
तो डेट वाली के साथ डेट कीवर्ड के साथ
जितने भी आपको रिजल्ट्स हैं वह सारी मिल
जाती हैं। सिर्फ आपको एग्जैक्ट बिन का
बाइनरी का पाथ नहीं मिलता है। सारे मिल
जाते हैं। इसमें आपको बाइनरी वाला भी मिल
जाएगा। देखो यूएसआर बिन डेट ये भी आपको
मिल जाएगा। लेकिन इसके साथ दिक्कत बस इतना
ही है कि ये जितनी भी कीवर्ड्स हैं डेट
रिलेटेड वो सारी देता है। तो व्हिच कमांड
यू कैन यूज़ इट्स बेटर एंड इट्स गुड टू
फाइंड द बाइनरीज़ एग्जैक्ट लोकेशन। तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यहां पे अभी तक आप लोगों को ये समझ में
आया तो हम आगे बढ़ते हैं। देन यू विल बी
अंडरस्टैंडिंग नेक्स्ट। बाकी यहां तक समझ
में आया सभी को? बता दीजिए।
एवरीवन यस।
प्लीज लेट मी नो
एवरीवन आई वांट रिस्पांस फ्रॉम एवरीबडी
हियर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
नॉट मच रिवाइज देखो अगर ध्यान से देखोगे
तो समझ में बिल्कुल आएगा। अगर आप ध्यान से
नहीं देखोगे तो नहीं समझ में आएगी। जो
ध्यान से देखेंगे इसमें कुछ अभी मैंने कुछ
तो बताया नहीं। मैंने तो बहुत सिंपल सा
बताया।
मैं तो बहुत सिंपल बताया अभी। अभी तो बहुत
डीप में गया भी नहीं। अगर फिर भी नहीं समझ
में आ रहा है आपको किसी को भी तो इसका
मतलब आप फोकस नहीं कर पा रहे हैं यहां पे।
फोकस करेंगे तो यह बहुत आसान है। मैंने बस
इतना बताया कि क्रोन टैब क्या होता है?
Linux में जॉब शेड्यूलर होते हैं। टास्क
शेड्यूलर होते हैं। एक टास्क को एक फिक्स
टाइम डेट पे एग्जीक्यूट करते हैं। उसके
लिए एक कमांड होता है क्रोन टैब स्पेस हफन
ई जो मैंने आपको कमांड यहां पे
ये कमांड होती है। क्रोन टैब
hन ई इसको एंटर करेंगे तो क्रोन की
कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल मिलेगी जो कि आपको
बेसिकली यह कॉन्फ़िगर करने में हेल्प करेगा
कि किस पर्टिकुलर मिनट पे, किस पर्टिकुलर
आवर पे, किस पर्टिकुलर डे ऑफ मंथ पे, किस
पर्टिकुलर मंथ में, किस पर्टिकुलर डे ऑफ
वीक पे एक टास्क को या एक स्क्रिप्ट को या
एक कमांड को चलाना है। दैट्स इट।
सिंपल
तो इट्स इट्स इजी बस इतना ही बताया मैंने
अभी तक।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब
मैं यहां पे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां से पहले बाहर निकल जाते हैं। अब मैं
यहां पर आगे बढ़ता हूं और आगे आपको चीजें
बताता हूं। देखो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हाय नितेश जी लिटिल लेट टुडे एज आई वास
ट्रेवलिंग फ्रॉम ऑफिस टू होम। इट्स ओके
पीतांबर दैट्स ग्रेट। आप आ गए अच्छी बात
है। जो रेगुलर हैं मुझे पता है मैं सबके
नाम भी जानता हूं जो रेगुलर अटेंड करते
हैं। ऑलमोस्ट आई नो एवरीबडीज नेम नाउ
क्योंकि काफी दिनों से ये क्लासेस चल रहे
हैं। तो मुझे आईडिया लग चुका है। एंड आई
एम हैप्पी दैट यू गाइस आर कंटीन्यूअसली
फॉलो कंटीन्यूअसली फॉलोइंग दिस सीरीज। टिल
नाउ 50 लोग कम से कम जो 50 लोग हैं मैं तो
हैट्स ऑफ
आई विल बी सेइंग कि हैट्स ऑफ टू देम टू
स्टिल बी इन द सीरीज।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] है। गॉट इट।
अभी तो समझ में आ गया होगा ना। अभी तो समझ
में आ गया होगा। चलिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
तो सिंटेक्स में जो पांच फील्ड है ये समझ
में आ गया। पहला मिनट, दूसरा आवर का,
तीसरा डे ऑफ़ मंथ का, मंथ का जो कौन सा दिन
है, कैलेंडर डे, चौथा मंथ इटसेल्फ और
पांचवा डे ऑफ़ वीक। वीक का कॉन्सर्ट है। यह
सारी यह एक कमांड का सिस्टम है। नेक्स्ट
की तरफ चलते हैं। अब इसी में कुछ स्पेशल
ऑपरेटर्स होते हैं। अब इस क्रोन टैब में
जब कॉन्फ़िगरेशन करेंगे, तो इसमें कुछ
स्पेशल ऑपरेटर्स होते हैं। अब ये स्पेशल
ऑपरेटर्स कौन-कौन से हैं? जैसे एक होता है
एस्टेरिस्क। स्टार। एस्टेरिस्क जिसको आप
स्टार बोलते हैं। ठीक है? क्या बोलते हैं?
एस्टेरिस्क। स्टार।
गॉट इट?
क्या हुआ? क्या हुआ? मतलब समझा नहीं। हेलो
सर क्या हुआ? क्या हुआ? क्वेश्चन में मुझे
मिला नहीं निसार तुम्हारा। क्वेश्चन बताओ।
क्वेश्चन बताओ।
ओके। ओके। ठीक है। ये है स्टेरिस्क। पहला
ऑपरेटर। एस्टेरिस्क का यूज़ का का मतलब
क्या होता है? एव्री पॉसिबल वैल्यू। ठीक
है? एव्री पॉसिबल जहां पे एस्टेरिस्क हो
इसका मतलब है
तो मतलब वो पूरा का पूरा एस्टेरिस का मतलब
वो पूरा पूरा जैसे कि मैं आपको बताता हूं
यहां पे यहां पे शुरू के पांच फील्ड्स में
पांचों में एस्टेरिस्क है इसका मतलब क्या
हुआ कि एव्री मिनट एव्री आवर एव्री डे ऑफ़
मंथ एव्री मंथ
एंड एव्री डे ऑफ़ वीक इसका मतलब है कि सारे
दिन सारे सारे मिनट सारे घंटे सारे महीने
सारे महीने महीने के दिन और सारे वीक जो
है आपको इस कमांड को चलाना है। मतलब हमेशा
ही चलाते रहना है। यह एस्टरिस्क का मतलब
हो जाता है। दिस इज़ द मीनिंग ऑफ
एस्टरिस्क। ठीक है? अब होता है दूसरा जो
स्पेशल ऑपरेटर है वो है कॉमा। इसका मतलब
होता है मल्टीपल डिस्क्रीट वैल्यूज़।
एग्जांपल 1 15 30 इन द मिनट फील्ड। ये
मिनट फील्ड के लिए स्पेशली जो होती है एक
मल्टीपल डिस्क्रीट वैल्यू को प्रोवाइड
करने के लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता है। कॉमा
मिनट फील्ड में। ठीक है? जो मिनट फील्ड है
आपका जैसे मिनट फील्ड कौन सा है आपका पहला
मिनट फील्ड होता है तो अब कॉमा देके आप उस
मिनट फील्ड में मल्टीपल वैल्यूस को इंसर्ट
कर सकते हो ठीक है 1 15 मतलब ऐसे करके तो
ये कॉमा इसलिए यूज़ में आता है दूसरा हफन
हफन क्यों होता है अ रेंज ऑफ़ वैल्यूस इन द
डे फील्ड फॉर मंडे टू फ्राइडे ये डे फील्ड
के लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता है यानी किसके
लिए यूज़ में लिया जाता है ये मंडे टू
फ्राइ फ्राइडे जैसे यह वाला
डे ऑफ वीक जो पांचवा फील्ड है आपका डे ऑफ
वीक तो मंडे ट्यूसडे वेडनेसडे उसके लिए
हफन में यूज़ में लिया जाता है। ये हमारा
हफन इसलिए मंडे वाली जो ट्यूसडे वाली जो
लास्ट फील्ड है आपकी जो कि आपका डे ऑफ वीक
है उसके उसके अंदर ये डिफाइन करने के लिए
लिया जा सकता है कि भैया मंडे टू वेडनेसडे
वेडनेसडे टू सैटरडे ऐसे चलाओ। समझ में आ
रहा है? इस तरीके से चलाओ। जैसे कि यहां
पे डे ऑफ़ वीक में ज़ीरो से सिक्स है। तो हम
इसको अगर कर देते हैं ज़ीरो से सिक्स का
मतलब है कि संडे से लेके सैटरडे तक चलाओ।
मतलब हर दिन ही चलाओ। संडे, मंडे,
ट्यूसडे, वेनेस, थर्सडे, फ्राइडे, सैटरडे।
ऐसे ही अगर आ रहा है यहां पे टू से फोर तो
टू पे कौन है? ज़ीरो पे संडे है, वन पे
मंडे है, टू पे ट्यूसडे है। यानी टू
ट्यूसडे से थर्सडे तक चलाओ। ठीक है? इस
तरीके से ये हफन यूज़ में आता है फॉर डे
वाली फील्ड। और उसके बाद एक फील्ड आता है
यहां पे स्लैश। स्लैश क्या होता है?
इंक्रीमेंट्स। एग्जांपल
एस्टेरिस स्लैश 10 इन द मिनट फील्ड मींस
एव्री 10 मिनट्स का स्लैश का यूज़ में लिया
जाता है। मिनट वाली फील्ड में जो सबसे
पहला फील्ड है अगर कुछ इस तरीके से ये
लिखा रहे मिनट फील्ड एस्टेरिस 10 इसका
मतलब है हर 10 मिनट में इस चीज को चलानी
है। इस पर्टिकुलर कमांड को या स्क्रिप्ट
को आपको चलानी है। इसलिए ये यूज़ में लिया
जाता है। तो यानी मिनट के लिए यहां पे
एस्टेरिस का यूज़ किया जाता है। ठीक है?
कॉमा का यूज़ किया जाता है और स्लैश का यूज़
किया जाता है। यह तीन चीजों का यूज़ मिनट
फील्ड में किया जाता है और बाकी एक जो हफन
है आपका उसका यूज़ जो है वो आपका डे वाली
फील्ड में किया जाता है। ऐसे बहुत सारे
ऑपरेटर्स आते हैं जो क्रोन के साथ यूज़
होते हैं। यहां पे मैंने आपको कुछ कॉमन
बेसिक ऑपरेटर्स बताए हैं जिनका यूज़ जनरली
किया जाता है। अब मैं आपको इसका लाइक
एग्जांपल भी बताता हूं ताकि आपको ज्यादा
अच्छे से समझ में आ जाए। देखिए
क्रron टैब को एडिट करने के लिए क्रron
टैब hन ई कमांड आपको चलाना पड़ेगा जैसा
मैंने आपको बताया। एंड अगर आपको कंटेंट
देखना है किसी यूजर के क्रron टैब का तो
क्रron टैब hfन l से उस यूजर का क्रron
टैब का कंटेंट आप देख सकते हैं। जैसे अगर
मैं कमांड चलाऊं यहां पे क्रron टैब hfन l
तो यहां पे ये किसी पर्टिकुलर यूजर का
करंट यूजर का क्रron टैब का जो लिस्ट है
वो दिख जाएगा कि उसमें क्या-क्या चीजें
मेंशंड है। अभी फिलहाल इसमें कुछ भी नहीं
है। तो यहां कुछ भी आपको नहीं आ रहा। तो
इस कमांड से वो देख सकते हैं आप। अब
यहां पर एक एग्जांपल मैं आपको दे दिखाता
हूं और इसके थ्रू आपको क्लियर समझ में भी
आ जाएगा। ठीक है? बैकअप अ डायरेक्टरी
एव्री नाइट एट 2:30 am ये मान लो काम आपको
करना है। एक डायरेक्टरी को बैकअप करना है
हर रात को 2:30 बजे 2:30 am तो इसको कैसे
लिखेंगे? देखो 2:30 am को आपको चलाना है।
तो टू तो आवर हो गया। 30 इज द मिनट राइट?
2 आर हो गया। 30 मिनट हो गया। तो पहला
फील्ड मिनट का होता है। तो हमने 30
दिखाया। दूसरा फील्ड हमारा
आर का होता है। अगर आपको याद नहीं आ रहा
है तो मैं पीछे कर देता हूं। पहला फील्ड
मिनट का दूसरा आर का होता है। तो हमने
पहला फील्ड में मिनट 30 दे दिया। दूसरा आर
टू दे दिया। और उसके बाद यहां पे बाकी के
तीन फील्ड्स जो हैं उसमें एस्टिस्क दे
दिया। इसका मतलब क्या हुआ? बाकी के तीन
फील्ड्स हैं। मंथ का कौन सा दिन है? कौन
सा महीना है और कौन सा वीक का दिन है?
रहेगा यानी कौन सा दिन है? तो यह तीन
एस्टरिस्क दिए यानी कि यानी कि हर
हर डे मंथ के हर डे पे हर महीने में और हर
दिन
ठीक है? मतलब ये हर डेट को आपको चलाना है।
हर महीने में हर दिन को आपको चलाना है।
इसका मतलब यही हो गया। तो यह एस्टर रिस्क
लगा दी गई है। यानी कि हर महीने हर डेट को
हर दिन आपको क्या चलाना है? 230 am पे
यानी रात को
2:30 में 2:30 am यहां लिखा हुआ है। तो
इसको हमने 302 कर दिया। और आपको क्या
चलाना है? यह कमांड चलानी है। कौन सी? Tar
zcf बैकअप होम TCZ होम यूजर। यानी कि इस
कमांड को आपको चलाना है और इसको बैकअप
लेना है। कहां पे लेना है? स्लैश होम
स्लैश यूजर वाली लोकेशन पे। इसका ये कमांड
चला के आपको बैकअप करनी है। तो ये आपने
क्रोन जॉब सेटअप कर दिया है। तो इस तरीके
से ये सेटअप होती है। पांच फील्ड्स तो
होते ही होते हैं जिसमें क्योंकि हमें
यहां पे क्या चलाना है? 2:30 am पे चलाना
है। तो हमको उसको मेंशन कर दिया। और यहां
पे डेली ही चलाना है 2:30 am पे। तो यहां
पे स्टार स्टार स्टार कर दिया। और बैकअप
वाली जो कमांड होती है वो बैकअप वाली
कमांड दे दी। दैट्स इट। सिंपल। यह समझ में
आया आपको बैकअप और डायरेक्टरी वाली चीज़?
यह आपको समझ में आया?
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल। अगर दोपहर का टू दो:30
होता 2:30 PM होता ये अगर तो यहां पे क्या
लिखते? यहां पे 30 तो 30 30 ही होता लेकिन
टू जो है वहां पे 14 हो जाता। 14 हो जाता।
राइट? बिल्कुल सही बात है।
आर यू गेटिंग दिस? अंडरस्टुड गाइस
एवरीबॉडी?
हां, एक तरह से ऑटोमेशन के लिए यूज़ में
आता है। करेक्ट।
हां, Suddo एप अपडेट भी हो सकता है। इस
तरीके से आप Sudo ऐप अपडेट कमांड भी चला
सकते हो। अपग्रेड कमांड भी चल चला सकते
हो। यह भी बिल्कुल कर सकते हो। आप चाहते
हो कि आपका सिस्टम हर एक वीक पे अपग्रेड
होता रहे उनके पैकेजेस तो एप अपग्रेड
कमांड को क्रron ऐप से सेटअप कर दो
अपग्रेड होता रहेगा वो हमेशा चलता रहेगा
लेकिन सिस्टम ओपन होना चाहिए याद रखिएगा
सिस्टम ओपन होना चाहिए उसके लिए आप
ठीक है अब देखिए अब यहां पे दूसरा दूसरा
एक सिनेरियो है रन अ सिक्योरिटी स्कैन ठीक
है रन अ सिक्योरिटी स्कैन एव्री संडे एट
मिडनाइट रन अ सिक्योरिटी स्कैन एव्री संडे
एट मिडनाइट। तो अब यह मिडनाइट की बात कर
रहा है। तो मिडनाइट का मतलब होता है रात
की 12:00 बजे। अब देखो 12:00 बजे का मतलब
क्या होता है? देखो यहां पे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ये 12:00 बजे
रात को 12:00 बजे यानी 12:0 पे। ठीक है?
तो यहां पे 12:00 बजे यहां पे 24 ऑवर
फॉर्मेट होता है। तो आर 12 होगा। तो ये 12
आर जो होता है 12 उसको हम ज़ीरो से डिनोट
करते हैं। तो ज़ीरो हो जाएगा। मिनट क्योंकि
12:0 हो गया तो मिनट भी जीरो हो जाएगा।
यानी पहले दो फेज जीरो जीरो होंगे। तो ये
जीरो जीरो यहां पे आपको दिख गया। उसके बाद
यह बोल रहा है एव्री संडे तो दिन वाला
यहां कांसेप्ट है। तो दिन वाला कांसेप्ट
पांचवा पांचवा फील्ड होता है। डे ऑफ द वीक
संडे। तो संडे कौन होता है? ज़ीरो होता है।
तो यानी कि पांचवा फील्ड भी ज़ीरो होगा। तो
पहला दो ज़ीरो हो गया। तीसरा चौथा छोड़
देते हैं। पांचवा फील्ड भी जीरो है। अब
तीसरा चौथा एस स्टार है यानी एस्टेरिस्क
है। इसका मतलब क्यों? ऐसा क्यों है?
क्योंकि ये संडे को हर महीने के संडे को
चलानी है आपको। है ना? तो तीसरा चौथा डे
ऑफ मंथ एंड मंथ। तो हर महीने आपको चलानी
है और हर महीने
के हर डेट को चलानी है आपको। क्योंकि यहां
पे स्पेसिफिक ऐसा तो नहीं है कि एक
पर्टिकुलर डेट पे ही चलानी है। राइट? ऐसा
तो नहीं है कि इस मंथ के
10 तारीख को ही सिर्फ चलानी है आपको या 15
तारीख को चलानी है। ऐसा नहीं है। हर दिन
हर तारीख को चलानी है। तो यहां पे जो बीच
के दो आपके फील्ड्स हैं जो दो फील्ड्स
किसके? डे ऑफ मंथ। मंथ का कौन सा दिन है?
तो भैया सारे दिन चलानी है। और कौन से
मंथ? तो सारे मंथ चलानी है। इसलिए यह
स्टार स्टार है। तो यहां पे 12:0 पे यानी
12 बज के रात रात को 12:00 बजे के आसपास
यहां पे ये क्या चलाना है? यहां पे डेली
चलानी है। और जीरो यानी संडे के संडे
मिडनाइट में रात को आपको क्या चलाना है?
सिक्योरिटी स्कैन। यानी यूएसए लोकल बिन
लाइन स्कैन सिस्टम। यह कोई एक टूल है। मान
लो कोई टूल है लाइनिस या कोई भी एक
सिक्योरिटी टूल है। उसको हम चला रहे हैं
और स्कैन कर रहे हैं सिस्टम को। इसका मतलब
यही हो जाता है। ठीक है
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
या
सर गिव अवे विनर्स को फ्री में कोर्स
मिलेगा या पे करना पड़ेगा? जो अरे यार
[हंसी]
क्या तुम भी क्या क्वेश्चन कर रहे हो? गिव
अवे का कोई विनर है तो उसको पे क्यों करना
पड़ेगा? उसको फ्री में मिलेंगे कोर्स जो
वीआईपीटी की हमारी कोर्स है ₹0000 फी है
उसकी वह फ्री में मिलेगी उनको ₹1 उनसे
चार्ज नहीं किया जाएगा ट्राईक का वन ईयर
का वाउचर फ्री में मिलेगा ₹1 भी चार्ज
नहीं किया जाएगा दैट्स इट
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सर आई एम अमित कुमार वीएपीटी बैच विनर आई
एम रिकॉर्डिंग देख लूंगा अभी सेमेस्टर
एग्जाम है अमित कुमार कोई बात नहीं अभी
सेमेस्टर एग्जाम दीजिए जो वीएपीटी का
एक्सेस जो मिलने वाला है वह अभी नेक्स्ट
जो वीएपीटी बैच बैच आएगी। आपको उसमें लाइव
बैच का एक्सेस ही मिलेगा। तो आपको बिल्कुल
फ़िकर नहीं करना है। अभी आप एग्जाम पे फोकस
कीजिए। जुलाई में नेक्स्ट बैच आएगी। उसके
लिए आपको कांटेक्ट भी किया जाएगा हमारे
तरफ से एंड आपको उसका एक्सेस मिलेगा। आप
उसमें आराम से लाइव क्लासेस अटेंड कर सकते
हैं।
नहीं नहीं
हरिक वेद पॉल विनर्स को कोई भी पेमेंट
नहीं करनी है। प्लीज डोंट स्प्रेड
मिसइफेशन। मिस मिस इनफेशन मत स्प्रेड
कीजिए आप। अ
गिव अवे का विनर ऑलरेडी चूज़ हो चुका है।
वो हम चूज़ कर रहे थे। हमारी तरफ से फाइनल
डिसीजन जो हमने जिनको चूज़ किया वो ऑलरेडी
वो लिस्ट आ चुकी है।
विनर कौन-कौन है डिफ्रॉनिक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के lindin पेज पे जाइएगा। वहां
आपको विनर्स की लिस्ट मिल जाएगी। अगर
जिनको नहीं पता आप सिंपल मैंने वैसे तो
बता दिया है बट स्टिल आप पूछ रहे हैं। तो
मैं वापस से बता देता हूं। Lindin पे आप
चले जाइएगा। जस्ट गो टू द Lindin।
ठीक है? यहां पे डिफ्रॉनिक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी Lindin पेज आपको देखने को
मिलेगी। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
इसको ओपन कर लीजिएगा।
एंड यहां पर पेज पोस्ट पर मतलब जो लेटेस्ट
पोस्ट है यह विनर्स की ही पोस्ट है। इसमें
आपको विनर्स की लिस्ट यहां पे मिल जाएगी।
ये जो विनर्स की लिस्ट है यू विल गेट द
लिस्ट।
ठीक है?
ओके। चलिए [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
अब यहां पे एक और एग्जांपल मैं आपको
दिखाता हूं। क्लीन अप स्लश टीएमपी लॉग्स
एव्री 15 मिनट। यानी जो टेंपरेरी लॉग्स
होते हैं जो टेंपरेरी वाले लोकेशन पे
स्लैश टीएमपी लोकेशन पे होते हैं आपके
टेंप फोल्डर में टेम डायरेक्टरी में उसके
लॉग्स को हर 15 मिनट पे आपको क्लीन करना
है ये आपको मान लो काम करवाना है रिमूव
करना है उसके अंदर की एंट्रीज को तो अब
क्या इसका कैसे चलाएंगे
एस्टेरिक्स
15 मैंने आपको यहां बताया था स्लैश का यूज़
कब करते हैं एस्टेरिक्स 10 का मतलब हर 10
मिनट में तो एस्टेरिक्स 15 का मतलब क्या
हुआ
एसिस का मतलब होता है हर हर
15 हर 15 मिनट में क्या करना है भैया आपको
स्लश टेम टेम के लॉग वाली जो भी फाइल्स
होंगी डॉट log वाली उन सबको रिमूव कर देना
है तो आर एम सटीएम
एस्टेरिस डॉट log मतलब उस पर्टिकुलर
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर जितने भी फाइल्स डॉट
log बनेंगे उन सबको डिलीट मार दो तो ये
क्या करेगा हर 15 मिनट पे डिलीट मारेगा
बाकी सब में स्टार स्टार आर यानी
एस्टरिस्क लगे हुए हैं। इसका मतलब आपको
समझ में आ चुका होगा कि यहां पे पहला मिनट
का हर आर हर घंटे हर डे हर मंथ हर डे हर
डेट पे हर मंथ के हर डे पे आपको इसको
हटाना है। मतलब हमेशा जो है इसको हर 15-15
मिनट पे इसको क्लीन करते रहना है। बस ये
चीज़ है। हां अगर इसमें आपको और एडिशन चीज
डालनी है। 15 मिनट पे इसको क्लीन करना है।
अगर आपको ऐसा करना है कि नहीं भाई हर 15
मिनट पे क्लीन तो करना है। आपके हर 15
मिनट पे। ठीक है? वी हैव टू क्लीन कि हर
15 मिनट पे क्लीन हो जाए। बट यह क्लीनिंग
आपको महीने के किसी पर्टिकुलर डेट को करनी
है। ठीक है? अगर ऐसा करना है तो आप
कैलेंडर डे तीसरे फील्ड में बता सकते हो।
जैसे मुझे अगर यहां पे तीसरे फील्ड में
मैं यहां पे यह जो तीसरा फील्ड है 1 2 3
यह तीसरा फील्ड है इसमें मैं अगर डेट डाल
दूं मान लो 15 डाल देता हूं डेट आई एम
पुटिंग द डेट 15 तो ये हर 15 डेट को 15-15
मिनट पे क्या करेगा एग्जैक्टली क्लीनिंग
करेगा रिमूव करेगा तो इस तरीके से आप
क्लोन जॉब को सेटअप कर सकते हो बहुत आसान
काम है राइट
बहुत आसान काम है
बहुत आसान काम है बहुत ईजी है आर यू
गेटिंग दिस?
यह थंबनेल में सूट का प्र्प क्या डाला था
जो इतना अच्छा बना है। [हंसी]
नहीं बताऊंगा। सब चीजें नहीं बताऊंगा।
थंबनेल एआई जनरेटेड है। अच्छी बन गई है।
अच्छा
बढ़िया प्र डाला है मैंने। मैंने कुछ ऐसा
इंटरेस्टिंग प्र्ट डाला था कि एकदम से
रियलिस्टिक इमेज वहां पे दिखा के थंबनेल
बनी है ना।
यह जो थंबनेल है यह एआई से बनाई हुई है।
जो आपको थंबनेल आजकल अभी रिसेंट वाले
क्लासेस एसओसी की क्लासेस के दिख रही हैं।
एआई जनरेटेड थंबनेल है। बट उसमें जो फोटो
है, इमेज है, वह खुद की ही इमेज है मेरी।
एंड दिस इज़ बीइंग जनरेटेड फ्रॉम चैट
जीपीटी।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
राइट?
चलिए
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके यह एग्जांपल्स आपको समझ में
एग्जांपल्स के थ्रू आपको ये फील्ड्स समझ
में आ गए पांचों फील्ड्स मुझे पहले ये
क्लियर कीजिए जल्दी जल्दी बताइए सभी लोग
इफ एवरीवन रिप्लाई देन आई विल बी मूविंग
फॉरवर्ड
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
प्लीज बताइए फटाफट
अंडरस्टुड
ओके
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके इसका मतलब यहां पे अगर इसी तरीके की
चीज आपको कॉन्फ़िगर करनी हो खुद से भी तो
आप कैसे कर सकते हैं? यहां पे क्रron टैब
हफन ई कमांड प्रेस करेंगे। आप इसके अंदर आ
जाएंगे क्रोन टैब वाले कॉन्फ़िगरेशन फाइल
में आई बटन प्रेस करेंगे इंसर्ट के लिए
क्योंकि मैं विम एडिटर यूज़ कर रहा हूं।
सबसे नीचे जाएंगे और यहां पे जो भी आपको
मेंशन करनी है, जिस तरीके से भी मेंशन
करना है। तो, सबसे पहले मुझे मेंशन करना
है मिनट। कितने मिनट पे ये एग्जीक्यूट
होना चाहिए? तो मैं अगर चाहता हूं कि ये
हर मिनट एग्जीक्यूट हो। हर मिनट
एग्जीक्यूट हो तो हर मिनट एग्जीक्यूट करने
के लिए क्या कर देंगे भाई? एस्टेरिस्क लगा
देंगे। यह मैं एस्टेरिस्क लगा दूंगा। अब
ये हर घंटे एग्जीक्यूट हो। मतलब ऐसा हो कि
भाई हर मिनट हर घंटे
ऐसे एग्जीक्यूशन हो। मतलब हर दिन ऐसे
एग्जीक्यूशन हो। तो मैं एस्टेरिस्क लगा
दूंगा। मैं फिर से स्टेरिक्स तीसरे पे भी
चौथे पे भी पांचवें पे भी ऐसे लगा दूंगा।
मतलब हर दिन हर मिनट आर ऐसे एग्जीक्यूट हो
जाए। क्या एग्जीक्यूट हो भाई? तो मैं
एग्जीक्यूट कर रहा हूं स्लैश यूएसआर बिन
स्लश डेट। मैं इस कमांड को मान लो ये
एग्जीक्यूट कराना चाहता हूं। तो मैंने उस
कमांड की पूरी पाथ दे दी। तो ये हर मिनट।
अब इसी में मुझे चाहिए कि नहीं यार ये हर
मिनट नहीं। ये हर अ 10 मिनट पे एग्जीक्यूट
हो। तो स्टेरिस्क 10 डाल दिया। तो ये इसका
मतलब क्या हुआ? कि हर 10 मिनट पे आपको इस
कमांड को डेली एग्जीक्यूट करना है। तो
एस्टेरिस स्लैश 10 लगा दिया। बाकी के
फील्ड्स को ऐसे कर दिया। यूएसआर बेंड डेट
एंड दैट्स इट। ये करके मैंने यहां पे कॉलन
डब्लू क्यू किया। सेव एंड एग्जिट बाहर। इस
तरीके से ये काम करता है। क्रॉन टैब हफन
एल करोगे तो अभी की जो एंट्री है वो दिख
जाएगी कि भ ये
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] एंट्री
फिलहाल इस यूजर के लिए पड़ी हुई है। तो हर
10 मिनट पे मैंने ये चीज़ ये मतलब सेटअप कर
दिया है कि हर 10 मिनट पे ये चीज़ हो। तो
इस तरीके से ये चीज काम करती है। राइट? अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ये तो आपको समझ में आ चुका होगा। आ गया
होगा। आ गया होगा। अब हम यहां पे नेक्स्ट
की तरफ बढ़ते हैं। अब यहां पे एक चीज को और
समझते हैं। वेयर क्रॉन लिव्स सिस्टम वाइड
वर्सेस यूजर। अब क्रॉन जो है वो
एग्जैक्टली रहता कहां है? वेयर द क्रॉन
लिव्स? क्रॉन भैया हमारे कहां रहते हैं?
तो एज अ एसोसिए एज एन एज अ एसोसिएट
एनालिस्ट यू नीड टू नो वेयर टू लुक फॉर
दीज़ फाइल्स ड्यूरिंग एन इन्वेस्टिगेशन। एक
इन्वेस्टिगेशन जब कर रहे हैं तो आप इन
फाइल्स को कहां-कहां देखें ये आपको पता
होना चाहिए। तो देखो दो तरह की क्रोन
टैब्स होते हैं। एक यूजर क्रोन टैब्स होते
हैं। एक सिस्टम क्रोन टैब्स होता है। दो
लोकेशनेशंस होती है। एक यूजर वाली होती
है। एक सिस्टम वाली होती है। यूजर वाली जो
होती है वो लोकेटेड होती है कुछ इस लोकेशन
पे वेयर
स्पूल क्रोन क्रॉन टैब्स कुछ इस लोकेशन पे
अह एक्सिस्ट करती है। दीज़ आर मैनेज्ड बाय
द क्रॉन टैब कमांड। यह क्रॉन टैब कमांड के
द्वारा मैनेज किए जाते हैं। यह कुछ लोकेशन
होती है वायर के अंदर। स्पूल क्रॉन क्रॉन
टैब्स अब इसको हम देखते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
चलते हैं वेयर कमांड के अंदर। वायर कहां
गया? ये रहा वायर। वेयर के अंदर में आप
जाएंगे तो यहां पे स्पूल स्पूल के अंदर
जाएंगे तो क्रॉन आपको मिलेगा। क्रॉन के
अंदर जाएंगे तो क्रॉन टैब्स मिलेगा। इसके
अंदर ये चीजें होती है। अब यहां पे आपको
रूट का मिलेगा। इसको राइट क्लिक करके माउस
पैड्स ओपन करेंगे तो आपको वहीं क्रron टैब
की कॉन्फ़िगरेशन देखने को मिलेगी जिसको हम
क्रॉन टैब hन ई से ओपन कर रहे थे। देखो आप
देख रहे हो Linux कितनी ब्यूटीफुल एक
लinक्स बेस्ड जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स हैं वो
कितने प्यारे होते हैं। कितने कितने
ब्यूटीफुल चीजें होती हैं इसके अंदर कि आप
राइट क्लिक करके टर्मिनल ओपन करोगे। मान
लो यहां पे मैं यहां पे इसमें आ जाता हूं।
और मैं जो कमांड चला रहा हूं ना ये क्रॉन
टैब हफन ये कमांड चला रहा हूं। अब ये
कमांड जो मुझे डी जो मुझे एग्जैक्ट चीज
फाइल ओपन करके दे रहा है वो फाइल यही वाली
ओपन करके दे रहा है। ये रूट वाली फाइल ये
रूट वाली जो फाइल है जो कहां पे सिचुएटेड
है भाई? यह सिचुएटेड है हमारे फाइल सिस्टम
के अंदर वेयर। वेयर के अंदर स्पूल स्पूल
के अंदर क्रॉन क्रॉन टैब्स और इसके अंदर
में एक फाइल है रूट। यह सिचुएटेड है यहां
पे। तो इसी को यह हमें ओपन करके दे रहा है
क्रोन टैब स्पेस हफन ई कमांड के थ्रू।
इतना ना ओपन करना पड़े आप डायरेक्टली सीधा
क्रैब hन ई ट कमांड टाइप कीजिए और आपके
सामने ये पूरा का पूरा जो यह फाइल है यह
इस तरीके से ओपन हो के आ जाएगा। यह एक
ब्यूटी है आपके लinक्स की जो आपको हर चीज
को फाइल के थ्रू प्रोवाइड कर देता है।
कमांड्स जो भी होती है।
इस तरीके से यह एक लोकेशन और एक लोकेशन
होती है सिस्टम क्रॉन टैब्स की सिस्टम ये
तो यूजर क्रॉन टैब का लोकेशन था। अब एक
सिस्टम क्रॉन टैब का लोकेशन होता है जो
कहां पे लोकेटेड होता है? स्लैश ईटीसी के
अंदर स्लैश क्रॉन टैब के अंदर या स्लैश
ईटीसी के अंदर क्रोन डॉट डी के अंदर। ठीक
है? दीज़ यूजुअली रिक्वायर रूट प्रिविलजेस
एंड इंक्लूड एन एक्स्ट्रा फील्ड फॉर द
यूजरनेम रनिंग द कमांड।
ठीक है? तो इसके अंदर होते हैं ईटीसी के
अंदर क्रोन टैब और क्रोनॉट अब मुझे ईटीसी
के अंदर जितने भी क्रोन वाले फोल्डर्स हैं
क्रोन से रिलेटेड उनको यहां पे लिस्ट करना
है तो मैं क्या कमांड डालूंगा कोई भी बताओ
कोई भी Linux के धुरंदर अगर यहां पे हो
जल्दी से बताओ बिना देखे ईमानदारी ऑनेस्टी
से कि मुझे ईटीसी के अंदर स्लश ईटीसी के
अंदर जितने भी क्रोन नाम से डायरेक्टरीज
या फाइल्स जो भी हैं उन सबको यहां देखना
है बस मुझे सामने सो व्हाट कमांड आई विल
बी यूजिंग?
जल्दी बताइए जल्दी फटाफट बताइए जितने लोग
1 मिनट का टाइम है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] लोकेट ईटीसी
क्रोन गलत ग्रेप कॉर्न गलत लोकेट क्रोन
गलत लिस्ट ईटीसी गलत लोकेट गलत लोकेट गलत
एलएस ईटीसी गलत लोकेट क्रैब गलत
रॉन्ग। अभी तक जितने भी आंसर आए हैं सबके
रॉन्ग हैं। मैंने पूछा ईटीसी के अंदर
क्रोन नाम से जितने भी डायरेक्टरी फाइल्स
हैं, मुझे उसको यहां दिखाना है। देखो
ग्रेप क्रोन टैब गलत। देखो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे इसके
लिए मैं जल्दी-जल्दी बता देता हूं। इसके
लिए ज इसके लिए एक कमांड डालते हैं। एलएस
कमांड। उसके बाद यहां पर स्लश एलएस कमांड
के बाद स्लश ईटीसी यानी ईटीसी के अंदर की
फाइल्स आपको दिखाओ। मैं यहां पे फिर से
एलएस स ईटीसी ये कमांड आप करेंगे। ठीक है?
ये आपने किया। उसके बाद आप कमांड चलाएंगे
ग्रेब का। ग्रेब और देन आप यहां पर क्या
करेंगे? क्रोन लिखेंगे।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यानी कि स्लश ईटीसी के डायरेक्टरी के अंदर
जितने भी चीजें हैं उसको पहले तो लिस्ट
करो एलएस कमांड से और यह पाइपलाइन देते
हैं। इसका मतलब यह होता है कि पहले कमांड
का आउटपुट दूसरे कमांड के लिए इनपुट हो
जाए। ग्रेप का मतलब यही होता है। सॉरी ये
पाइपलाइन का मतलब यही होता है। और ग्रेप
का मतलब हम एक किसी कीवर्ड को खोज रहे
हैं। बस तो हमने क्या किया?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ये बात को समझ
लीजिएगा। कई लोगों को नहीं समझ में आती
है। मैं आपको समझा रहा हूं। तो इसको
समझिएगा। ठीक है?
यहां पर समझिएगा इस चीज को। एलएस कमांड का
मतलब है लिस्ट करना। लिस्ट किसको कीजिए?
ईटीसी के अंदर की जो भी डायरेक्टरी फाइल्स
हैं सबको लिस्ट कीजिए। ठीक है?
यही चीज है। अब यहां पे अब
पाइपलाइन
मतलब कि इस पर्टिकुलर पूरे कमांड की
आउटपुट को इस दूसरे कमांड के लिए इनपुट कर
दीजिए। यानी इसका आउटपुट सारे लिस्टिंग
होंगी और इसमें इनपुट चली जाएगी। तो अब
इसमें यह सर्च करेगा क्रोन को। तो अब अब
मैं एंटर करूंगा तो जितनी भी क्रोन
रिलेटेड फाइल्स या जो भी डायरेक्टरीज है
वो सारी यहां पे आपको देखने को मिल जाएगी।
दैट्स इट। [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
अब समझ में आ गया शायद? अब समझ में आ गया
ये चीज?
आर यू गेटिंग?
रिकबेद पॉल आपने सीधा ग्रेप कॉर्न बोला था
शायद इस वजह से
आपका मैंने वो आंसर नहीं लिया था। राइट?
आपने सीधा ग्रेप कॉर्न बोल दिया था। ग्रेप
मतलब क्रॉन जो होता है वह बोल दिया था।
राइट?
यह अंडरस्टुड है आपका? समझ में आ गया यह
कमांड का मतलब?
आपको नहीं पता है ना हरिक वेद पॉल आपने
पूरा सिंटेक्स ही नहीं बताया पूरा
सिंटेक्स बताना होता है ऐसे नहीं होता है
लिनिक्स में कि ग्रेप क्रॉन बोल दिया उससे
आपका वो रिजल्ट आ गया ऐसा नहीं होता है
पूरा बताओ ना एलएस ईटीसी कौन बताएगा और
उसके पहले ग्रेप के पहले पाइपलाइन आती ही
आती है ऐसा इसने आपको ऐसा आपको किसने बोल
दिया ग्रेप के पहले पाइपलाइन आती ही आती
है ऐसा बिल्कुल जरूरी नहीं है ग्रेप एक
इंडिपेंडेंट कमांड है ग्र ग्रेप से आप
डायरेक्ट किसी चीज में सर्च कर सकते हो।
किसी भी डायरेक्टरी में जाके। यू डोंट नीड
पाइप लाइन। पाइप लाइन तो तब चाहिए जब इसका
इनपुट आपको ग्रेप के लिए आउटपुट चाहिए।
राइट? तो इस बात को समझो। जब कांसेप्ट
आपको ना पता हो तो उसको क्लियर करो। उसको
पूछा करो। आपका आंसर गलत था। आपने सीधा
ग्रेप क्रॉन बोला था। दैट वाज़ टोटली
रॉन्ग। ठीक है? समझ में आपको? आई होप समझ
में आ गया होगा। राइट? पहले एलएस ईटीसी
होगा देन ग्रेप क्रॉन होगा। सिर्फ ग्रेप
क्रॉन से आपका वह आंसर नहीं आने वाला है।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
गॉट इट।
चलिए अब यहां पे क्रोन डी क्रोन डेली ये
कुछ डायरेक्टरीज आपको यहां पे देखने को
मिल रही हैं। क्रोन डी डेली आवरली मंथली
ये सब इसके अंदर में होती है। अब मैं आपको
ना इसके अंदर ईटीसी के अंदर अगर मैं लेके
चलूं तो आपको यह सारी डायरेक्टरी जो है
देखने को मिल जाएंगी। यही चीज मैं यहां पे
आपको बता रहा था।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] या
कि दो तरीके होते हैं। एक यूजर क्रोन
टैब्स जो कि इस लोकेशन पे बता दिया। एक
सिस्टम क्रोन टैब जो ईटीसी क्रोन टैब के
अंदर होता है और ईटीसी क्रोनॉट के अंदर
होता है। दो चीजें होती हैं। तो दोनों
चीजें आपको यहां पे मिल मिल चुकी है। एक
क्रोन टैब भी है ईटीसी के अंदर में और
क्रोन डॉट भी है। यानी बिल्कुल हम सही जा
रहे हैं। राइट? अब चलिए
अब यहां पे एक पीरियडिक फोल्डर्स भी होते
हैं। जैसा मैंने दिखाया आपको। जब मैंने
सर्च किया तो आपको यहां दिखाया है कि etc
क्रron डॉट डेली यानी जिसमें डेली वाले
क्रोन के टास्क हैं उसकी यह फोल्डर है।
आवरली वाले ये हैं, मंथली वाले ये हैं। तो
ये भी फोल्डर्स होते हैं जिसमें आप
शेड्यूल करते हो। जैसे अगर कोई आपने वीकली
शेड्यूल किया है, मंथली, आवरली, डेली वाली
शेड्यूल किया है, वो भी यहां पे आपको
देखने को मिल जाते हैं। तो, ये सारी चीजें
इस जगह पे आपको मिल जाती है। ठीक है? यह
लोकेशन होता है।
अब यहां पे आते हैं व्हाई इट मैटर्स फॉर
एसओसी एल1 एनालिस्ट? ये इतना मैटर क्यों
करता है? क्रॉन जो है व्हाई इट इज़ सो मच
ऑफ मैटर फॉर एसओसी एल1 एनालिस्ट। मतलब
क्यों मैटर करता है? राइट? तो इसका दो-तीन
मतलब इसका लॉजिक है वो मैं आपको बताता
हूं। पहला तो डिटेक्टिंग पर्सिस्टेंस द
एविल क्रोन अटैकर्स ऑफेन क्रिएट अ क्रोन
जॉब टू इंश्योर देयर मालवेयर रिस्टार्ट
इवन इफ द सर्वर रिबूट्स सर्वर रिबूूट करे
सिस्टम रिस्टार्ट हो कुछ भी हो क्रोन के
थ्रू हटाकर जो है अपने मालवेयर्स को हमेशा
एक स्पेसिफिक इंटरवल पे एग्जीक्यूट कराता
कराता रहेगा। सिनेरियो क्या है? यू सी अ
वियर्ड आउटबाउंड कनेक्शन टू अ C2 कमांड
एंड कंट्रोल सर्वर एव्री आवर ऑन द डॉट हर
कुछ हर घंटे आप एक आउटबाउंड कनेक्शन देख
रहे हो कि ये कनेक्शन बन रहा है एक C2
सर्वर से कमांड एंड कंट्रोल सर्वर से तो
ये थोड़ी सी ऑड आपके लिए होनी चाहिए
इन्वेस्टिगेशन में क्या करेंगे आप चेक ऑल
क्रोन टैप्स सारे क्रोन टैब्स चेक करेंगे
आप जितने भी क्रोन टैप्स हैं यू विल चेक
दैट राइट
यू माइट फाइंड फाइंड कुछ इस तरह का एंट्री
जीरो एस्टरिस्क एस्टेरिस्क एस्टेरिस्क
एस्टरिस्क यह पहला मिनट मिनट वाला होता है
तो मतलब ज़ीरो यहां पे मिनट है यहां पे
एस्टरिस्क एस्टेरिस कर्ल http कर्ल कमांड
चला हुआ है मेलिशियस साइट शेल डॉट एसए और
ये बैश गैब अह सॉरी पाइपलाइन बैश यानी कि
इस कर्ल कमांड को चलानी है शेलॉटsh को
लाना है और बैश पे एग्जीक्यूट कर देनी है
उसको तो यह कमांड आपको दिखा रहा है कि
भैया एक शेल का एग्जीक्यूशन किया जा रहा
है। हर मिनट मतलब आपको यह एग्जीक्यूशन
देखने को मिल रही है। एंड आपका यह जो है
मैलवेयर हो सकता है। मैलवेयर का
एग्जीक्यूशन एक हो सकता है। राइट?
ये आपको समझ में आ चुका हो। तो कुछ इस
तरीके का होता है। पर्सिस्टेंस को डिटेक्ट
करने के लिए क्रोन का यूज किया जाता है।
एंड [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एन एसओसी
एनालिस्ट आपके लिए काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है।
ऑटोमेटिंग [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
डिफेंसिव टास्क एल1 एनालिस्ट कैन यूज़
क्रॉन टू मेक देयर ओन लाइफ इज़ियर। आप एज
एन एसओसी एल वन अपने आप की लाइफ को भी
आसान बना सकते हैं क्रॉन के थ्रू से। एक
तो अटैकर के पर्सिस्टेंस अटैकर के अह जो
अटैकर का एक अह अह एक वे है पर्सिस्टेंस
लेने का उसको डिटेक्ट करने के लिए यूज़ कर
सकते हैं। सारे क्राउन टैप्स को चेक
कीजिए। और दूसरा आप अपने आसान का काम को
आसान बनाने के लिए लॉग रोटेशन। एनश्योर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] लॉग्स डोंट फिल
अप द डिस्क एंड क्रैश द एसआईएम एजेंट।
आपको यह देखना है कि भैया लॉग्स इतने ना
बन जाए। इतने लॉग्स ना बन जाए कि वो पूरी
डिस्क फुल हो जाए और एसआईएम का जो आपका
एजेंट है या एसआईएम का जो आपका टूल है वो
क्रैश कर जाए। तो उसके लिए लॉग का क्लियर
करना हर कुछ-कुछ टाइम पे इसके लिए आप
क्रोन चला सकते हैं कि हर कुछ टाइम पे
लॉग्स क्लियर हो जाए या तो वो लॉग्स जहां
पे लॉग फाइल्स जहां पे स्टोर हो रही है
वहां से मूव करके कहीं और चली जाए। कहीं
और स्टोर हो जाए। किसी एक्सटर्नल
ड्राइव पे या एक्सटर्नल कोई पेनड्राइव या
एक्सटर्नल स्टोरेज डिवाइस पे स्टोर हो जाए
और यहां से डिलीट हो जाए तो स्पेस हमेशा
मेंटेन रहेगी। ऑटोमेटेड हेल्थ चेक सेंड एन
अलर्ट इफ अ क्रिटिकल सिक्योरिटी सर्विस
लाइक ऑडिट डी और फेल टू बैन स्टॉप्स
रनिंग। कुछ क्रिटिकल सर्विज होती हैं।
ऑडिट डी करके, फेल टू बैन करके ये सर्विज
क्रिटिकल सर्विज होती हैं। तो आपको यह
देखना है कि कोई ऐसी सर्विस जो है वो अगर
स्टॉप हो जा रही है या रुक जा रही है तो
भैया यहां पे एक अलर्ट भेजना ताकि आप अलॉट
भेज दीजिए। भैया ऐसी कोई एक इंपॉर्टेंट
सर्विस कोई मान लो Windows का सिस्टम 32
के अंदर कोई Windows की सर्विस है। अब वो
अचानक से रुक जाए या ऐसा हो जाए तो उसको
तुरंत नोटिफाई कर दिया जाए एक अलर्ट के
थ्रू। वैसे ही यहां पे कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट
सर्विज होती हैं। उनका अगर कोई स्टॉप हो
जाता है कुछ अगर ऐसा कुछ नहीं रन हो रहा
है तो उसमें अलर्ट एक तुरंत अलर्ट भेज
दीजिए कि भैया ये सर्विज स्टॉप है इसको
देखा जाए। स्नैपशॉर्टिंग रेगुलरली
एक्सपोर्ट्स अ लिस्ट ऑफ रनिंग प्रोसेससेस
टू अ फाइल फॉर बेसलाइन कंपैरिजन। मतलब अब
रेगुलरली स्नैपशॉटिंग का मतलब है कॉपी
बनाना या एक तरह से बैकअप
एक पर्टिकुलर चीज की बैकअप तैयार करना।
मतलब क्या है कि कुछ रनिंग प्रोसेससेस हैं
आपके सिस्टम में जैसे बहुत सारे
प्रोसेससेस रन हो रहे हैं तो हर कुछ टाइम
पे ठीक है हर कुछ घंटे या हर कुछ ऐसे जो
भी आप टाइम डेट क्रोन टैब के थ्रू असाइन
करना चाहें आप चाहते हैं हर घंटे ऐसा हो
या हर कुछ दिन पे ऐसा हो तो रनिंग
प्रोसेससेस की लिस्ट जो है एक फाइल में
सेव करते जाइए स्टोर करते जाइए ताकि आपको
पता चले कि किस दिन कौन-कौन सी प्रोसेस चल
रही थी कोई सा प्रोसेस कोई डेंजरस या
मलशियस तो नहीं या कुछ ऐसा वो भी इसके
थ्रू आप बता सकते हैं। मतलब इस तरीके के
इन्वेस्टिगेशन में आपकी हेल्प कर सकता है
क्रॉन जो है। तीसरा जो है लॉग एनालिसिस
क्रॉन लॉग्स जिसको बोलते हैं। ये भी काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज है। व्हेन इन्वेस्टिगेटिंग
एन इंसिडेंट एज़ एन एसओसी एल1 जब आप किसी
इंसिडेंस की इन्वेस्टिगेशन कर रहे हैं।
चेक वेयर लॉग सिसलॉग और वेयर लॉग क्रॉन टू
सी व्हिच जॉब्स वेयर एग्जीक्यूटेड। ये
लोकेशन होती है जैसे वेयर के अंदर में लॉग
के अंदर में सिस लॉग एक लोकेशन होती है।
ठीक है? जैसे मैं अ
वेर के अंदर में लॉग के अंदर जब आप जाएंगे
तो यहां पे एक आपको मिलेगा सिस लॉग। ठीक
है? अगर यहां पे अगर क्रिएटेड होगा तो
आपको मिल जाएगा।
लेट्स सी हम
आई डोंट थिंक इट्स क्रिएटेड। चलिए ये
क्रिएटेड नहीं है क्योंकि कोई अभी
एग्जीक्यूशन नहीं हुई है। बट कोई और
एग्जीक्यूशन नहीं हुई है तो नहीं है।
क्रॉन वाली एग्जीक्यूशन तो शायद नहीं हुई
होगी तो वो भी क्रिएट नहीं हुई होगी। आई
डोंट थिंक कि ये क्रिएट हुई होगी। नहीं है
यहां पे। तो इस लोकेशन पे वायर लॉग के
अंदर में जैसे ही कोई क्रॉन या क्रॉन जॉब
या किसी तरह का कोई क्रॉन आपने सेटअप किया
है वह एग्जीक्यूट जब होगी तो यहां पे एक
लॉग फाइल क्रिएट हो जाती है। ठीक है? जो
अभी नहीं क्रिएटेड है क्योंकि कोई क्रॉन
रन नहीं हुई है। ठीक है? अब यहां पे वो
क्रोन जॉब फाइल जो है वो कुछ इस तरीके से
आपका [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] siss
log के अंदर में या क्रron क्रॉन के अंदर
में आपका वो स्टोर होगा। तो आपको ये जो
लोकेशनेशंस है इसको चेक आउट करते रहना है
कि यहां पे कौन-कौन से क्रॉन जॉब्स
एग्जीक्यूट हुए हैं। कोई एग्जीक्यूट होगा
तभी ये फाइल क्रिएट होगा। अदरवाइज ये फाइल
आपको वहां पे नहीं दिखने वाली है। ठीक है?
तो वायर के अंदर लॉग के अंदर में ये चीजें
भी आप देख सकते हैं। यू कैन सी दिस
थिंग्स। राइट? तो इस तरीके से आप देख के
आप एग्जैक्टली लॉग्स की एनालिसिस कर सकते
हैं। देख सकते हैं भाई कौन-कौन से लॉग्स
या कौन-कौन से एग्जैक्टली क्रोन जॉब्स जो
है वो चले हैं। उसके अंदर एग्जैक्टली क्या
चला है? कोई मैवर्थ एग्जीक्यूट नहीं हुआ
है। किसी तरह का कोई पर्सिस्टेंस लेने की
कोशिश तो नहीं की गई है। कोई ऐसा फाइल
एग्जीक्यूट तो नहीं हुआ है या बैकग्राउंड
में तो कहीं पे भेजा नहीं गया है जो नहीं
भेजनी चाहिए थी। किसी रिमोट लोकेशन पे तो
फाइल नहीं गई है। यह सारी चीजें आपको वहां
पे लॉग्स के अंदर में देखना पड़ेगा। ठीक
है? यह आपको समझ में आ गया होगा। अब देखिए
सिक्योरिटी एक रेड फ्लैग क्या है? यह भी
मैं आपको बता देता हूं। व्हाट इज द एक रेड
फ्लैग? अ जॉब रनिंग अंडर www डेटा। वेब
सर्वर यूजर दैट एग्जीक्यूट्स अ स्क्रिप्ट
इन स्लैश स्टेप। मतलब एक कोई जॉब रन हो
रही है वेब सर्वर के अंदर। ठीक है? है
यूजर वेब सर्वर यूजर है और उसने एक
स्क्रिप्ट को एग्जीक्यूट किया स्लश टीएमपी
में। तो, यह एक रेड फ्लैग हो सकता है कि
एक वेब सर्वर जो यूजर चला रहा है उसने
स्लैश टेंप डायरेक्टरी जो कि टेंपरेरी
डायरेक्टर है। उसमें एक स्क्रिप्ट को
एग्जीक्यूट कर दिया जो कि इसके लिए कोई
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। कोई जरूरत नहीं है
क्योंकि वो वेब सर्वर से कनेक्टेड है। वो
किसी फाइल को भी कहीं भेज सकता है। किसी
पर्टिकुलर चीज को होस्ट कर सकता है। तो ये
एक डेंजरस चीज है। यह एक रेड फ्लैग हो
सकता है। तो इसको आपको ध्यान में रखना
चाहिए। सिक्योरिटी बेस्ड प्रैक्टिस अगर की
हम बात करें हार्डनिंग की बात करें यहां
पे क्रॉन हार्डनिंग बोल लीजिए यानी कि
क्रॉन को सुरक्षित करने की बात करें
सिक्योरिटी के पर्पस से तो टू प्रिवेंट
अनअथराइज्ड यूज़र्स फ्रॉम यूजिंग क्रोन यू
कैन यूज़ ईटीसी क्रोन डॉट अलाउ
ठीक है ओनली यूज़र्स लिस्टेड हियर कैन यूज़
क्रोन etc क्रोन डॉट डिनाई यूज़र्स लिस्टेड
हियर आर ब्लॉक्ड ये दो फाइल्स को आप यूज़
कर सकते हैं यह ये दो फाइल्स को यू कैन
यूज़। अब ये जो फाइल्स हैं अगर आपको मैं
दिखाऊं तो ये फाइल्स आपको जनरली देखने को
नहीं मिलेंगे। मैं आपको यहां पे दिखाता
हूं। ईटीसी के अंदर चलते हैं। ईटीसी के
अंदर अगर मैं क्रोन सर्च करूं क्रोन तो
यहां पे क्रोन डॉट अलाउ अगर सर्च करूं तो
यू विल नॉट फाइंड एनीथिंग। आपको कुछ भी
नहीं मिलेगा। इसलिए क्योंकि क्रोन से
रिलेटेड यहां पे अभी हमने कोई भी काम नहीं
किया है। तो अगर यह फाइल आपको नहीं मिल
रही है ईटीसी के अंदर में। जैसे मैंने
यहां पे एलएस करके भी आपको दिखाया था। अ
इफ आई एम प्रेसिंग द एलएस
पता नहीं कहां गया। चलो वापस से टाइप कर
टाइप कर लेते हैं। स्लश एलएस ईटीसी मैंने
किया था। उसके बाद यहां पे गैप एंड देन
अगर मैं क्रोन डॉट अलाऊ करूं। क्रोन डॉट
अलऊ तो ये कुछ भी खोज के नहीं दे रहा मुझे
क्योंकि यहां पे कुछ है ही नहीं है। ऐसा
फाइल ही नहीं है। क्रॉन करूं तो सारे मिल
जाएंगे। क्रॉन डॉट अलाऊ आपको कहीं पे
देखने को नहीं मिल। तो अगर ऐसा नहीं है
कहीं तो आप इस लोकेशन पे ये फाइल क्रिएट
खुद कर सकते हैं क्रोन वाली उसके लिए विम
करेंगे क्रोन डॉट सॉरी
यहां विम कर दिया यहां पे अब इसको आपको
क्रिएट कहां करना है ईटीसी में तो स्लश
ईटीc के अंदर में क्रron डॉट अलाऊ ऐसा
फाइल आपको क्रिएट करना है एंटर करेंगे
आपको फाइल ये क्रिएट हो जाएगी क्रोन डॉट
अलाऊ अब इसके अंदर जो एंट्री करनी है
क्रॉन डॉट अलाऊ की जो एग्जैक्ट सिंटेक्स
होती है उसके अंदर उसके अकॉर्डिंग आप
इसकी एंट्री कर दीजिए और क्रोन डॉट अलाउ
फाइल क्रिएट हो जाएगी। उसी तरीके से क्रोन
डॉट डिनाई फाइल भी आप क्रिएट कर सकते हैं
और उसके अंदर में आप एंट्री कर सकते हैं।
अब उसमें होगा क्या? उसके अकॉर्डिंग होता
क्या है [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
कि अगर ये फाइल्स यहां पे एक्सिस्ट करती
हैं। आपने यहां पे मान लो बना दिया है।
ठीक है? तो ओनली यूजर अगर क्रोन डॉट अलाऊ
फाइल आपने बना लिया है। सिर्फ क्रोन डॉट
अलाऊ भी मान लो आपने बनाया बनाया है। तो
जो यूज़र्स यहां लिस्टेड होंगे वही क्रोन
को यूज़ कर पाएंगे। तो उसमें आपने लिख दिया
रूट यूजर तो सिर्फ रूट यूजर कर पाएगा उसको
यूज़। अगर क्रोन डॉट अलाउ एक्सिस्ट करता है
तो लinक्स क्रोन डॉट डिनाई को कंप्लीटली
इग्नोर कर देता है। क्रोन डॉट डिनाई का
कोई मतलब नहीं रह जाता इस फाइल का। अगर
क्रोन डॉट अलाऊ एग्ज़िस्ट करता है तो लेकिन
अगर एक्सिस्ट नहीं करता क्रोन डॉट डिनाई
ओनली है तो उसमें जो यूज़र्स लिस्टेड हैं
वो ब्लॉक्ड रहेंगे। वो एक्सेस नहीं कर
सकते हैं क्रोन वाली चीज को फीचर्स को।
ठीक है? और अगर कोई भी दोनों में से
एक्सिस्ट नहीं करता है तो यह लinक्स
डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन के ऊपर में है कि या तो
सभी यूज कर सकते हैं क्रॉन को या तो सिर्फ
रूट यूज कर सकता है। ये उस डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन
के ऊपर में राइट
ऑल राइट?
आई थिंक यू गॉट इट गाइस। सभी लोगों को समझ
में आ गया?
आर यू अंडरस्टैंडिंग? प्लीज प्लीज लेट मी
नो एवरीबॉडी।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके।
गुड।
आगे की तरफ चलते हैं। अब यहां पर एसओसी
थ्रेट्स की बात करें तो एक पर्सिस्टेंस
का थ्रेट रहता है। अटैकर कैन गेट द
पर्सिस्टेंस
अ
थिंग फ्रॉम द क्रॉन क्रॉन टैब एंड एक
रिवर्स सेल्फ पर्सिस्टेंस भी रहता है।
दोनों ही रहता है। अटैकर यहां पे अगर मान
लो अटैकर ने कुछ इस तरह की कोई एंट्री कर
दी है जिसमें आप देख सकते हैं हर 10 मिनट
पे malwaresh को आपको रन करना है। इट मींस
एव्री 10 मिनट्स एंड एव्री आवर एव्री डे
एव्री मंथ एव्री वीक डे आपका malvware
डॉटsh जो है चलेगा। रन malvware.sh एव्री
10 मिनट्स फॉर एवर इसका मतलब यही होता है
कि malvwaresh को हर 10 मिनट पे हमेशा
चलाते रहो। तो ये पर्सिस्टेंस का मैटर है।
पर्सिस्टेंस कुछ इस तरीके से क्रिएट की
जाती है आपके एसओसी एनवायरमेंट में।
रिवर्स सेल पर्सिस्टेंस की बात करें तो
देखो शेल का मतलब शेल लेना का मतलब होता
है कि एक अटैकर विक्टिम से कनेक्ट हो रहा
है। ठीक है? और रिवर्स शेल का मतलब हो रहा
है कि विक्टिम अटैकर्स से वापस से कनेक्ट
कर रहा है। वापस से विक्टिम अटैकर्स को
कनेक्ट बैक कर रहा है। यह रिवर्स शेल होता
है। कुछ इस तरीके की एंट्री यहां पे आपको
देखने को अगर मिल जाती है। इसका मतलब क्या
है कि हर मिनट
हर घंटे हर दिन हर मंथ हर वीक डे पर आपको
क्या चलानी है? यह कमांड चलानी है। क्या
करना है? बैश शेल को ल्च करना है। बैश हफन
आई यानी कि बैश का इंटरेक्टिव शेल स्टार्ट
करना है। और इसको कनेक्ट करना है अटैकर की
आईपी से और इस पोर्ट पे 444 पे यह आपको
चलानी है। कनेक्ट टू अटैकर आईपी गिव रिमोट
कमांड एग्जीक्यूशन।
यह आपको चलानी है। तो, यह
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] कमांड का
मतलब यहां पर यह हो जाता है कि आपको हर
मिनट, हर घंटे, हर दिन आपको जो है एक बैश
शेल ल्च करना है। इस पर्टिकुलर आईपी और इस
पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट पे और रिमोट कमांड
एग्जीक्यूशन करनी है। यानी कि कमांड
एग्जीक्यूट करने का पावर हमें देना है। हम
उस पे हटाकर कोई सा भी कमांड रन कर सकता
है। क्योंकि बैश की शेल एग्जीक्यूट हो रही
है। तो उस पे हटाकर कोई भी कमांड चला
लेगा। तो ये जो है दिस इज द रिवर्स शेल
पर्सिस्टेंस थ्रेट दैट एसओसी के लिए जो कि
आपके लिए प्रॉब्लमेटिक बीइंग एन एसओसी
आपके लिए प्रॉब्लमेटिक हो सकती है एंड
आपको इन चीजों का ध्यान रखना चाहिए। ठीक
है? [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] रियल
एसओसी सिनेरियो की हम बात करें तो एसओस
अगर मान लो देखो ऐसा हो सकता है कि एसएसएच
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो जाए। क्रॉन जॉब ऐड हो जाए
और पर्सिस्टेंट रिवर्स सेल जो है वो
एग्जीक्यूट कर दी जाए। कुछ इस तरीके की
सिनेरियो हो सकती है। अगर आप है एक एसओसी
एनालिस्ट हैं तो एसएसएच कंप्रोमाइज़ होके
क्रोंजो ऐड हो जाएगा और रिवर्सल
पर्सिस्टेंट स्टार्ट किया जा सकता है। तो
जब आप एक एसओसी एनालिस्ट के तौर पे काम कर
रहे हैं और लinक्स मशीन को एनालाइज़ कर रहे
हैं तो आपको यह नहीं पूछना है व्हाट कमांड
रन? कौन सा कमांड रन हुआ है? आपको यह
पूछना है व्हाई वाज़ इट यूज़्ड? क्यों यह
कमांड यूज़ हुआ है? व्हाट व्हाट वाज़ अटैकर
ट्राइंग टू अचीव अटैकर? क्या चाह रहा था
अचीव करना? व्हाट चेंज्ड आफ्टर
एग्जीक्यूशन? इस कमांड के एग्जीक्यूट होने
के बाद एग्जैक्टली क्या-क्या चेंजज़ आए
हैं। लॉग्स देख के भी और लॉग्स में
क्या-क्या चीजें आपकी जनरेट हो रही हैं वो
भी आपको देखना है। लॉग्स भी चेक आउट करना
है। तो लॉग वाली चीज देखो एसओसी का मतलब
है लॉग एनालिसिस। एसओसी का सिंपल मतलब है
जितने लॉग्स को आप अच्छे से एनालाइज़ कर
पाएंगे, जितने अच्छे से इन्वेस्टिगेट कर
पाएंगे, उतना ही ज्यादा अच्छा रिजल्ट आप
दे पाएंगे, उतनी अच्छे से अलॉटिंग कर
पाएंगे, ट्रैगिंग कर पाएंगे, एस्केलेटिंग
कर पाएंगे। ये सब कुछ लॉग पे डिपेंड करता
है। सब कुछ आपके नॉलेज पे और लॉग्स को
समझने के लिए आपको सारी चीजों की पूरी
ओवरऑल नॉलेज लेनी पड़ती है। दिस इज़ द
एसोसिएट एलनिस्ट L1 ठीक है?
हां समझ में आ गया? अब यहां पे कुछ
कमांड्स हैं Linux के जो मैं आपको बताना
चाहता हूं। एंड ये जो कमांड्स हैं मैं
आपको एक चीज बताना चाहूंगा। उस चीज को
ध्यान रखिएगा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब यह कमांड्स बहुत बेसिक कमांड्स हैं
Linux के अंदर में। मैं इसको कॉपी करता
हूं एंड आई एम ओपनिंग इट इनसाइड द वर्ड।
ठीक है?
मैंने इसको यहां पे पेस्ट कर दिया इस
कमांड को इन कमांड्स को। ठीक है? मैं यहां
पे एक थोड़ा सा ज़ूम कर लेता हूं।
राइट? आपको क्लियर थोड़ा दिख जाएगा। यू कैन
सी हियर। राइट?
आपको दिख रहा है अब यहां पे यह कुछ
कमांड्स है
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ₹20 का सुपर
चैट आई एम रोहित ओके ओके थैंक यू रोहित
थैंक यू इटो वायरस फॉर द सुपर चैट आई
नोटिस इट नाउ पहले नोटिस नहीं किया था
मैंने
ठीक है। चलिए वैसे सुपर चैट की जरूरत नहीं
है। वैसे नॉट नीडेड
या ऐसा हो गया तो काम खत्म। बिल्कुल सही
बात है।
Linux कमांड शीटशीट में यहां पे मैं आपको
कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट कुछ कमांड्स आपको दिखा रहा
हूं। हालांकि देयर आर मल्टीपल कमांड्स इन
लinक्स दैट यू शुड मास्टर बीइंग एन एसओसी
एल1। आपको कमांड्स जो हैं वह थोड़े से
प्रैक्टिस करने पड़ेंगे Linux के अंदर में।
उन कमांड्स के साथ आप जरूर अ फमिलियर होना
चाहेंगे क्योंकि
वो जो कमांड्स हैं वो आप यूज़ करेंगे डे टू
डे लाइफ में एंड यू विल बी अ बीइंग एन
एसओसी एल1 आप उन कमांड्स को चलाएंगे रन
करेंगे। तो देखो कमांड्स जैसे गैप नेटst
पीएस टॉप सीएच मोड सी सीए ओन टेल ऐसे बहुत
सारे कमांड्स हैं। एलएससी डी कैट लेस डीएफ
फ्री हु हिस्ट्री फाइन डी यू बहुत सारे
देयर आर मल्टीपल कमांड्स हैं। इनके अलावा
और भी बहुत सारे कमांड्स हैं। ये तो बस एक
एग्जांपल कमांड्स हैं। बट मैं आपको एक
रिकमेंड करूंगा सभी लोगों को जो भी इस
ट्रेनिंग के पार्ट हैं जो इस ट्रेनिंग को
फॉलो कर रहे हैं। आई वुड रिक्वेस्ट
एवरीबडी YouTube पर आप जाइएगा।
यह काम जरूर करना है YouTube पर
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी YouTube चैनल है। इसको
ओपन कर लीजिएगा। ठीक है? इसको तो आप ओपन
करेंगे। इसको तो आप देखेंगे। ठीक है? बट
YouTube पे जाके आपको सर्च करना है
टेक्निकल नेविगेटर।
अब यह मुझे नहीं पता कि आप में से कितने
लोग इस चैनल को जानते हैं या इस चैनल से
फमिलियर हैं। आपको टेक्निकल नेविगेटर चैनल
पर जाना है। हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू आर फमिलियर
विद दिस? टेक्निकल नेविगेटर
बताता हूं। रुद्र टेक्निकल नेविगेटर इस
चैनल पर आपको आ जाना है। ठीक है? एंड जहां
पे लगभग 168,000 सब्सक्राइबर्स आपको दिख
रहे होंगे। 400 प्लस वीडियोस दिख रहे
होंगे। दिस इज द वन ऑफ द वन ऑफ़ आवर ओल्ड
चैनल जिस पे मैं बहुत पहले बहुत टाइम से
एक्टिव हुआ करता था। इस पे मैंने बहुत
टाइम दिया है इस चैनल को। बहुत ज्यादा दिल
से टाइम दिया है हमेशा से। एंड साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के आपको इस पे डिफरेंट टाइप ऑफ
ट्यूटोरियल्स, क्लासेस एंड अ लॉट ऑफ
थिंग्स यू विल सी हियर जो आपको यहां पे
देखने को मिलेगा। राइट?
इस पर्टिकुलर चैनल के ऊपर में। एंड
यहां पर आपको एग्जैक्टली
प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन और पता नहीं
क्या-क्या चीजें मिलेंगी देखने को। तो आप
यहां पे देख सकते हैं आगे इस चैनल को। बट
यहां पे मेरा मेन मोटिव है इस चैनल पे
लाने का कि आपको इस चैनल पे आना है। आपको
जाना है प्लेलिस्ट्स के अंदर में। यू हैव
टू गो टू प्लेलिस्ट्स। यहां पे आपको
प्लेलिस्ट के अंदर में आपको एक काली लinx
की प्लेलिस्ट मिलेगी। यू विल सी अ
प्लेलिस्ट
ऑफ काली linx आप स्क्रॉल करके आइएगा
स्क्रॉल करते आइएगा यहां पर काली लinक्स
की एक प्लेलिस्ट मिलेगी
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] इस प्लेलिस्ट
में व्यूफ प्लेलिस्ट कीजिएगा सबसे नीचे आ
जाइएगा प्लेलिस्ट में व्यू फुल प्लेलिस्ट
कीजिएगा काली लinक्स वाली इसमें काली
लinक्स के सारे बहुत सारे वीडियोस मिलेंगे
आपको इन वीडियो सब सारे वीडियोस को नहीं
देखने आपको क्या करना है देखो आपको क्या
करना है काली लinक्स का यह पार्ट वन पार्ट
टू पार्ट थ्री पार्ट फोर ठीक है एंड पार्ट
फाइव
पार्ट पार्ट फाइव के बाद यह पार्ट सिक्स
पार्ट सिक्स बस पार्ट सिक्स तक यानी पार्ट
वन से ले पार्ट सिक्स तक के वीडियोस को एज
अ टास्क आपको देखना है। इन वीडियोस को जब
आप देख जाएंगे तो यहां जो मैं आज आपके
सामने ये कमांड्स बता रहा हूं। यह जो
कमांड्स मैं आपको दिखा रहा हूं एसओसी के
लिए यह तो कुछ भी नहीं है। ये तो बहुत
छोटे से बेसिक्स कुछ कमांड्स मैं आपको बता
रहा हूं। इनसे बहुत ज्यादा कमांड्स एंड
बहुत यूज़फुल कमांड्स आप सीख जाएंगे इन
वीडियोस को देख के। सिक्स पार्ट्स देखने
हैं। इसमें यार 39 वीडियोस हैं। 39
वीडियोस नहीं देखनी है आपको। शुरू के ये
जैसे पार्ट वन लिखा है ना, पार्ट टू लिखा
है, पार्ट थ्री लिखा है, पार्ट फोर लिखा
है, पार्ट फाइव लिखा है एंड पार्ट सिक्स
लिखा है। बस ये वीडियो छह देखने हैं आपको।
दैट्स इट।
बस और कुछ नहीं हृद ओके रिक्वेद पॉल का
ऑलरेडी हो चुका है बहुत अच्छी बात है आपने
पहले ही कर लिया है आप ओल्ड सब्सक्राइबर
रहे होंगे डेफिनेटली तभी
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे बाकी
जो लोग भी न्यू है जो लाइक नहीं जानते वो
प्लीज इन छह वीडियोस को देख लीजिए आपकी
लाइफ जो है ना सेट हो जाएगी कमांड्स को
लेके यू विल बी फीलिंग ग्रेट आफ्टर वाचिंग
दिस आपको सारे कमांड्स इतने अच्छे से समझ
में आ जाएंगे क्योंकि एक-एक चीज एक्सप्लेन
करके मैंने यहां पे बताई है हर कमांड्स
एंड वो सारे कमांड्स आपके लिए इंपॉर्टेंट
होंगे बीइंग एन एसओसी एनालिस्ट एल1 ठीक है
तो यह प्लीज देख लीजिएगा सभी लोग इट्स अ
रिक्वेस्ट टू एवरीबॉडी टू गो एंड वॉच दी
सिक्स पार्ट वीडियोस ठीक है सभी लोग का हो
जाएगा ये देख लेंगे बता दीजिए एक बार
एवरीवन विल डू दिस टास्क और इसका नोट्स
बना के कमांड्स की क्या आपने सीखा पॉइंट्स
बना के lindin पर डालिएगा और डेफ्रोनिक्स
को मुझे टैग कर सकते हैं आप टैग कीजिएगा
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके
गॉट इट
यस बहुत अच्छी बात है। गुड वेद
जिन्होंने पहले कर लिया है आप वापस से अगर
भूल गए होंगे चाहते हो तो वापस से आप यू
कैन अगेन स्टार्ट राइट। तो अब यहां पे कुछ
कमांड्स की बात करते हैं। एक कमांड होता
है ग्रेप। जैसा मैंने आपको बताया पहले ही
बताया ग्रेप सर्च टेक्स्ट पैटर्न्स इन
फाइल्स। टेक्स्ट पैटर्न्स को फाइल्स के
अंदर में सर्च करने के लिए ग्रेप कमांड का
यूज़ में लिया जाता है। ग्रेप के बाद
ऑप्शंस होते हैं। पैटर्न होता है, फाइल
नेम होता है। ठीक है? तो ग्रेब कमांड का
यूज़ में ले। अब कोई भी कमांड की
अगर आपको डिटेल जाननी है, मैनुअल अगर उसका
एक्सिस्ट करता है, तो मैन कमांड लिख के उस
कमांड का नाम दे दीजिए। तो उसकी मैनुअल
ओपन हो जाएगी। जैसे कोई कमांड ऑलरेडी
सिस्टम कमांड है। उसका मैनुअल अगर सिस्टम
में आपके उस मशीन में उस Linux
डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन में एग्ज़िस्ट करता है। तो
आपको करना क्या है? सीधा मैन कमांड डालना
है मैनुअल के लिए और उस कमांड का नाम लिख
देना है ग्रेब। तो आपका क्या हो जाएगा कि
उस पर्टिकुलर कमांड की पूरी डिटेल किस
तरीके से यूज़ करना है? वो कमांड क्या करता
है? कौन-कौन से ऑप्शंस है उसके साथ यूज़
होने वाले? सब कुछ आपको यहां पे मिल
जाएगा। मैन स्पेस ग्रैब करके एंटर कर
दीजिए। एंड आपको ग्रैब कमांड की पूरी
डिटेल जो है वो आपको मिल जाएगी। तो आप देख
सकते हैं यहां पे नाम इसका गैप ई ग्रेप एफ
ग्रेप ये सब लाइक इसके अलग-अलग रूप रूप
हैं। यहां पे इसका यूज़ करने का तरीका क्या
है? गैप ऑप्शंस पैटर्न्स एंड फाइल कुछ इस
तरीके से होता है। अब इसमें क्या-क्या
यहां पे ऑप्शंस आपको देखने को मिलते हैं?
तो लाइक कौन-कौन से एट्रब यहां पे
एट्रिब्यूट्स आप यूज़ कर सकते हैं। तो हफन
एफ जो है। ठीक है? यह आप यूज़ कर सकते हैं।
यहां पे डिस्क्रिप्शन में यह कुछ
डिस्क्रिप्शन इसके दिए हुए हैं। अब इसमें
ऑप्शंस में आप आते हैं तो ऑप्शंस में आपको
यहां पे मिल जाते हैं। hfन एफ, hन v, hfन
ई, hfन जी, hन पी ये सारे आपको ऑप्शंस मिल
जाते हैं। मैचिंग कंट्रोल्स में आपको hन
स्मॉल ई, हफन स्मॉल F, hन स्मॉल आई। ये
मैचिंग कंट्रोल में आपको ये सारी चीज़ मिल
जाती। तो आपको पूरा डिटेल मिल जाएगा कि
कैसे इस कमांड को एग्जैक्टली यूज़ करना
होता है। तो अगर आपको गैब ऐसे चलाना है
नॉर्मली। जैसे आप डेस्कटॉप पे भी अगर आपको
गैब चलाना है तो मैं आपको यहां पे गैप ऐसे
करके चला सकता हूं कि मुझे कोई पर्टिकुलर
कीवर्ड डालनी है। मैं डिफ़्रॉनिक्स सर्च
करना है तो मुझे यहां पे अगर कोई
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] स्पेशल कोई
स्पेसिफिक कोई कीवर्ड सर्च करनी है तो गैब
स्पेसिफिक जो भी डिफ़्रॉनिक्स अगर कोई
कीवर्ड है कुछ ऐसा है जो मुझे चलानी है तो
मैं वो चला सकता हूं। राइट? तो और मैं वो
सर्च कर सकता हूं। तो यहां पे बेसिकली
इसका कमांड का सिंटेक्स क्या हो जाता है
कि यहां पे पैटर्न आपको दे देना है। जो भी
पैटर्न आप देना चाहते हैं और उसके बाद जो
भी फाइल नेम देना चाहते हैं वो फाइल नेम
जिसके अंदर एग्जैक्टली आपको खोजना है या
जो भी चीजें करनी है वो फाइल नेम दे सकते
हैं। व्हाटएवर फाइल नेम यू वांट टू गिव वो
आप चला सकते हैं। अब यहां पे कुछ कॉमन
ऑप्शंस वगैरह होते हैं। वो कॉमन ऑप्शंस आप
यूज़ कर सकते हैं। व्हाटएवर ऑप्शंस यू आर
गोइंग टू यूज़ यू कैन यूज़ दैट। तो आप
सिंपली जैसे मैं अगर मान लो मैं यहां पे
एलएस करता हूं। ठीक है? डिफ्रontxt फाइल
है। राइट? अब मैं यहां पे करता हूं गैब और
यहां पे मुझे एक सर्च करनी है। क्या सर्च
करनी है? अ हम डिफॉल.xt के अंदर में
हम
पैटर्न मान लो लेट्स सपोज़ मुझे हेलो सर्च
करना है और मुझे डिफ़्रॉनिक्स.xt में ये
सर्च करना है। कुछ इस तरीके से। तो इस
तरीके से फाइल अगर कुछ हेलो टाइप का कुछ
मिला तो ठीक है मैं कैट डिफ्रॉनिक्स डॉट
टाइप करता हूं सॉरी कैट डिफ्रॉनिक्स देखता
हूं इसके अंदर कुछ है क्या सब्सक्राइब टू
अ
डिफ्रॉनिक्स डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी है ठीक है
तो मैं अगर गैब करता हूं यहां पे
हम
टू
यहां पे यह गैप अब हां एक चीज़ और देखो अगर
तुम जैसे गैब अगर मान लो तुम कोई चीज़ को
गैब कर रहे हो कोई चीज़ को एक्स तो यहां पे
मैं डिफ़्रॉनिक्स टीf txt से गैब करूंगा तो
मैं यहां पे एलएस करके डिफ़्रॉनिक्स या कैट
कमांड यूज़ कर लूंगा कैट डिफ़्रॉनिक्सटी कर
दूंगा ठीक है तो मैंने इससे इसके कंटेंट
व्यू करने हैं मुझे और उसके बाद मुझे
ग्रेब करना है क्या हेलो को मान लो हेलो
करना है या डिफ़्रोन सब्सक्राइब करना है
अगर देखना है इसे तो मैं एंटर करूंगा तो
अगर मुझे यहां पे कुछ सब्सक्राइब कोई
कीवर्ड से रिलेटेड कोई ऐसा कुछ मिलता है
तो मैं वो चीज कीवर्ड यहां पे मेरे को मिल
जाएगा। ऐसा अगर मेरे को मैं मान लो करो
एलएस करता हूं और मैं यहां पे गैब करता
हूं और यहां पे सब्सक्राइब लिखता हूं इस
तरीके से या इसको मैं ऐसे करता हूं फुल
फॉर्म में
सब्सक्राइब कुछ इस तरीके से। तो मुझे यहां
पे फिलहाल कोई रिजल्ट यहां पे नहीं आ रहा
क्योंकि यहां पे मुझे पर्टिकुलरली इस
सब्सक्राइब के कंटेंट अंदर के कंटेंट को
यह खोज के मुझे कुछ भी नहीं दे रहा कि
लाइक व्हाट आई एम सर्चिंग फॉर क्योंकि
यहां पे मैंने कैट का यूज़ नहीं किया। अब
मैं अगर यहां पे सेम चीज़ अगर मैं यहां पे
कुछ इस तरीके से करूं।
मैं यहां पे अब क्या कर क्या करना चाहता
हूं? इफ आई वांट टू सर्च दिस पर्टिकुलर
डेस्कटॉप डायरेक्टरी। कि मुझे इस डेस्कटॉप
डायरेक्टरी पे जो भी चीजें हैं उसमें से
कोई एक पर्टिकुलर फाइल निकाल। मैं एलएस
करता हूं यहां पे और गैब करता हूं। और
मुझे यहां पे डिफ्रॉनिक्स से रिलेटेड अगर
कुछ चाहिए कि डिफ्रॉनिक्स से रिलेटेड अगर
इस पर्टिकुलर पाथ पे कोई चीज है तो मुझे
दिखाओ भाई मुझे बताओ भाई तो ये उस चीज को
खोज के देगा बट अंदर के कंटेंट को व्यू
करने के लिए आप कैट कमांड यूज़ करते हो तो
यू विल बी यूजिंग द कैट कमांड दैट्स व्हाई
हम यहां पे अगर कैट कमांड यूज़ कर रहे हैं
तो हम क्या करते हैं कि हम उस पर्टिकुलर
टेक्स्ट फाइल के अंदर में कोई चीज़ ढूंढ
रहे हैं। एक पर्टिकुलर टेक्स्ट के अंदर
में कोई चीज़ ढूंढ रहे हैं तो उसके लिए हम
कैट कमांड यूज़ कर रहे हैं। बट अगर नहीं
अगर ऐसा नहीं है तो आप सिंपल एलएस कमांड
से यहां पे ग्रेप डिफ़्रॉनिक्स या उम यू
कैन सर्च उम
अ डिफ़्रॉनिक हां डिफ़ॉन सर्च कर लो। तो
यहां पे dfinx.xt जो भी फाइल्स अवेलेबल
हैं या व्हाटएवर अह अह व्हाटएवर लाइक अह
व्हाटएवर लाइक यहां पे आपको एक फाइल को
देखना है। फाइल को निकालना है या कोई सा
भी एक पर्टिकुलर पैटर्न के लिए फाइल को
ढूंढना है तो वो आप पैटर्न को ढूंढ सकते
हो। उस पैटर्न को जैसे डेफ्रॉनिक्स पैटर्न
को ढूंढ रहे हैं। तो डेफ्रॉनिक्स पैटर्न
यहां पे आपके सामने देखने को आ गया। जैसे
हमने वहां पे ईटीसी में खोजा था। वैसे ही
सेम सेम तरीके से आप यहां पे देख रहे हो।
ठीक है? तो इस चीज को आप पैटर्न को समझते
हुए आप एग्जैक्टली खोद सकते हो। गैब कमांड
का यूज़ करके यू कैन सर्च इट। अब उसी तरीके
से केस को इग्नोर करना है। ये केस
सेंसिटिव होता है। ऑब्वियसली बात है। बिना
केस ये केस सेंसिटिव होता है। तो अगर आपको
केस को इग्नोर करना है तो हफन आई कमांड
लगा दीजिए। तो ये केस को जो है इग्नोर कर
देगा। कोई सा भी लोअर केस अपपर केस में वो
काम चलेगा। उसी तरीके से नेट स्टैट कमांड
होता है। यह डिस्प्ले नेटवर्क कनेक्शंस
लिसनिंग पोर्ट्स एंड स्टैटिस्टिक्स। तो ये
क्या बताता है कि जितने भी नेटवर्क
कनेक्शंस अभी हैं वो आपको बताता है नेट
स्टैट कमांड। नेट स्टैट के बाद एएनटीपी
लगा देंगे तो सारे एक्टिव टीसीp कनेक्शंस
आपको दिखाता है। नेट स्टैट कमांड में
नेट स्टैट वन ए एन टीपी अ यहां पे ये सारी
चीजें यहां पे आपको बताता है। बट स्टिल
अभी यहां पे कुछ शो नहीं हो रहा। ऑब्वियस
सी बात है क्योंकि अभी कोई नेटवर्क
कनेक्शंस अह यहां पे चल नहीं रहा होगा
इसलिए वह दिखा नहीं रहा। बट यहां पे
दिखाते हैं सारे नेटवर्क कनेक्शंस। फिलहाल
क्योंकि कोई भी नेटवर्क कनेक्शंस यहां पे
अभी अवेलेबल नहीं है। तो आपको यहां पे
लिस्ट में कोई सा भी आपको यहां पे देखने
को नहीं मिल रहा है। बट जनरली आपको यह
नेटवर्क कनेक्शंस जो है वो आपको दिखाता
है। जो भी एक्टिव नेटवर्क कनेक्शंस है वो
दिखाता है। पीएस जो है वही सेम प्रोसेससेस
के बारे में बताता है। लाइक करंट
प्रोसेससेस कौन से चल रहे हैं, क्या चल
रहे हैं वो आपको ये तो आपको पता ही होगा
कि करंट कौन-कौन सा प्रोसेस अभी रन हो रहा
है वो प्रोसेससेस आपको बता देता है। टॉप
जो है रियल टाइम व्यू ऑफ़ सिस्टम प्रोसेस
एंड रिसोर्स यूज़। अब इस कमांड का यूज़ में
यूज़ जब आप लो लेते हो तो ये रियल टाइम्स
जो आपका सिस्टम का रिसोर्स यूटिलाइजेशन हो
रहा है सब कुछ हो रहा है वो सब कुछ आपको
बताता है। जैसे काफी लोग पूछते हैं Linux
में भाई कैसे सर पता करेंगे कौन सा
रिसोर्स क्या यूटिलाइज हो रहा है सब कुछ
तो आपको CPU कितना यूज़ हो रहा है मेमोरी
कितनी यूज़ हो रही है आप देख सकते हैं यहां
पे सीपीयू परसेंटेज का यहां पे आपको दिख
रहा होगा कौन सा पर्टिकुलर एक प्रोसेस
आईडी यहां पे जो है चल रही है कौन सा यूजर
उसको चला रहा है वो सारी चीजें कितनी
मेमोरी यूज़ ले रहा है यह सब कुछ आपको
बताएगा कितने देर से चल रहा है वह सब कुछ
आपको बताएगा तो रियल टाइम में जो भी आपके
प्रोसेससेस या जो भी आपके जो प्रोसेससेस
चल रहे हैं जो जो उसकी डिटेल देगा कितनी
मेमोरी यूज़ कर रहा है, कितना CPU यूज़ कर
रहा है, कितने टाइम से चल रहा है, कौन से
कमांड के थ्रू चल रहा है वो सब जो है आपको
ये बता देता है। तो ये टॉप कमांड आपकी
होती है। राइट?
हां, इसमें मल्टीपल सब कमांड्स होते हैं।
तभी मैंने बोला वो वीडियो जरूर देखिएगा आप
लोग। सीएच मोड आपको मैंने यह बता चुका है।
ऑलरेडी बता दिया है कि फाइल की चेंज फाइल
की परमिशन चेंज करने के लिए यूज़ में आता
है। सीएच ऑन जो होती है ये चेंज फाइल या
डायरेक्टरी ओनर एंड ग्रुप। किसी फाइल या
डायरेक्ट हर फाइल या डायरेक्टरी जो होता
है उसका एक ओनर होता है। उसका एक ग्रुप
होता है। ये आपको मैंने पहले बताया। अब
उसका ओनर चेंज करना है। किसी फाइल का ओनर
ही चेंज करना है। यानी कि रूट यूज़ मान लो
कोई ओनर है वो उसका अ रूट यूजर है। अब
उसका चेंज करना है या किसी और यूजर को
बनाना है। तो वो आप सीएच ऑन कमांड से आप
कर सकते हैं। टेल कमांड ये लास्ट फाइल की
लास्ट कुछ एंट्रीज को बताता है। टेल कमांड
का मतलब होता है लास्ट की। जैसे अब टेल
हफन फाइव और फाइल नेम आप दे दीजिए। तो
लास्ट फाइव का जो जो भी होगा वो आपको यहां
पे बताएगा। ठीक है? तो लास्ट फाइव ने
अ लाइक लास्ट फाइव का जैसे जो भी आपकी
एंट्रीज होंगी वो आपको बताता है। इसी का
एक सब एक एक सिमिलर कमांड हेड होता है तो
वो हेड कमांड भी होता है। तो उसे टॉप की
दिखाता है। ये टेल जो है वो लास्ट की
दिखाता है। ठीक है? तो इसका जो सिंटेक्स
होता है कुछ इस तरीके से आप देख सकते हैं
कि टेल के बाद हफन एन 20 लास्ट 20 लाइंस
के लिए फिर या हफन एन फाइव कर दोगे तो
लास्ट फाइव लाइंस की एंट्रीज दिखाता है।
किसी भी फाइल के अंदर में वो एंट्रीज
दिखाएगा। जैसे कि अगर मैं आपको यहां पे
दिखाऊं तो मैं कोई से भी फाइल देखते हैं।
देयर आर सम मोर एंट्री जैसे यहां पे ये है
ना हे एवरीवन राम नमस्ते सब्सक्राइब टू
डिफोनश एकडमी अ हेलो ऐसे करके ये फाइल है।
तीन लाइंस की फाइल है। राइट तो मैं अगर
देखना चाहूंगा तो मैं यहां पे लास्ट का
टेल करूंगा। टेल एंड यहां पे हफन मान लो
लास्ट का टू लाइंस यहां पे दिखाना है। तो
यहां पे डिफ़्रॉनtxt कर देंगे।
तो यहां पे लास्ट का जो दूसरा जो वो है वो
दिखा देगा टू लाइंस जो भी है। तो ये एक
स्पेस के साथ है क्योंकि मैंने स्पेस दिया
हुआ है। तो मैं इसको अगर ओपन करके मैं
यहां पे स्पेस हटा देता हूं।
राइट? ये तीन लाइंस हो गई हैं। अब मैं
यहां पे सेम कमांड रन करता हूं। तो लास्ट
के जो दो लाइंस हैं ये इस फाइल का वो दिखा
देता है। टेल हफन टू एंड डिफ़्रॉनिक्स.xt
तो लास्ट का टू लाइन क्या है? सब्सक्राइब
टू डिफ़्रॉनिक्स एंड हेलो। देखो पहला लाइन
नहीं दिखाया इसने। हेलो हे एवरीवन राम राम
नमस्ते वाली जो लाइन है वो नहीं दिखाई
लास्ट का टू लाइंस इसने शो कर दिया है बस
ये चीज है लास्ट के थ्री लाइंस मुझे तीनों
लाइन शो करने हैं तो मैं यहां पे थ्री कर
दूंगा अ लाइक
थ्री एंड लास्ट के ये तीन लाइंस आपको दिखा
देगा ठीक है तो इस तरीके से हेड भी होता
है टॉप के थ्री लाइंस टॉप के टॉप के लाइंस
जो है वो दिखाने के लिए थ्री फाइव जो भी
आपको दिखाना है वो एलएस लिस्ट करने के लिए
डायरेक्टरी को ये सबको पता है एलएस कमांड
यूज़ होता है सीडी डायरेक्टरी को चेंज करने
के लिए एक डायरेक्टरी री से दूसरे
डायरेक्टरी लोकेशन पे जानी है तो सीडी
कमांड यूज़ होती है। यह आप सबको पता है।
कैट कमांड किसी भी फाइल के कंटेंट को व्यू
करने के लिए जैसा कि अगर cd कमांड से जैसे
मुझे अगर मैं यहां पे डेस्कटॉप में हूं
अभी और मुझे जानी है ईटीसी डायरेक्टरी
में। तो मैं cd etc करूंगा तो मैं ईटीसी
में चला गया। यहां पे यहां पे पहले
डेस्कटॉप था। अब मैं ईटीसी में आ गया।
एलएस कमांड से इसके पूरी लिस्ट देख लें कि
जितने भी फाइल्स डायरेक्टरी हैं सब दिखा
देगा यहां पे। वो देखने के लिए होता है।
राइट?
कैट कमांड जो है एंड फिर वही चीज है यह
सारे कमांड्स आपको मिल जाएंगे कंटेंट
देखने के लिए कैट स्पेस अ मैं अगर
डेस्कटॉप पे आ जाऊं एंड मैं यहां पे कैट
स्पेस डिफ्रॉनिक्स लिखूं तो ये डेfronic्स
के कंटेंट्स को दिखा देगा कि भैया क्या
कंटेंट है ये सारी चीजें हैं। उसी तरीके
से लेस है व्यू फाइल कंटेंट पेज बाय पेज
मतलब फ़ाइल के कंटेंट को पेज बाय पेज यह
दिखाता है लेस जो कमांड होता है और कुछ भी
नहीं तो मतलब कोई भी फाइल है जैसे मैं लेस
करता हूं डिफ़ॉनीxt
तो देखो ये [हंसी]
इस तरीके से आपको ये दिखाता है कंटेंट बाय
कंटेंट कुछ विम के अंदर में ऐसे कुछ इस
विम टाइप लोकेशन में तो ये लेस कमांड का
भी यूज़ करते हैं काफी लोग कंटेंट अ फाइल
कंटेंट पेज बाय पेज एक पेज दूसरे पेज कई
सारे उसमें है तो ये आप यूज कर सकते हैं।
ठीक है? तो बहुत सारे लार्ज फाइल्स हैं
जिसके अंदर बहुत बड़ी-बड़ी एंट्रीज है।
बहुत बड़ी-बड़ी फाइल्स हैं। तो आप लेस
कमांड का यूज़ कर सकते हैं उस फाइल के
अंदर के कंटेंट्स को देखने के लिए। ठीक
है? बहुत बड़ी फाइल्स हैं। तो इसको यूज़
किया जा सकता है। डीएफ कमांड होती है
डिस्क स्पेस यूसेस के लिए। डिस्क स्पेस का
यूज़ देखना है आपको कि कौन सी आपकी जो फाइल
सिस्टम है या लोकेशन है वो कितना डिस्क
स्पेस ले रही है। तो स्लैश डेव एसडीए ये
हमारा मेन हार्ड डिस्क है। ये 46% ले रही
है। बाकी सब थोड़े-थोड़े ले रहे हैं। तो
ये आपको वो दिखा देता है। फ्री तो यह
मेमोरी यूसेस का बताता है। कितने मेमोरी
अभी फ्री हैं? कितने यूज़ ऑलरेडी हो रहे
हैं ये सारा। तो टोटल मेमोरी कितना है
आपका? कितना यूज़ हो चुका है? कितना फ्री
हो चुका है। बफर कैश कितना है? अवेलेबल
कितना है? वो सारी चीजें आपको दिखाता है।
Linux में मेमोरीज़ वगैरह जो है वो सारी
चीज़ आपको यहां पे ये दिखा देते हैं। हु
कौन से यूज़र्स जो है भैया जो है अभी
करेंटली लॉग्ड इन है। वो कमांड हु दिखाता
है। तो मैं रूट कमांड रूट यूजर से लॉग्ड
इन हूं। अभी तो रूट दिखा रहा है। उसी
हिस्ट्री जो है ये कमांड्स की हिस्ट्री
दिखाता है। कौन-कौन से कमांड अभी तक आपने
टाइप किए हैं यह सबको पता होगा। तो ये
हिस्ट्री जो सारे कमांड जो हमने टाइप किए
हैं अभी रिसेंटली वह सारे कमांड्स की
लिस्ट आ जाएगी। फाइंड जो है यह बेसिकली
क्या होता है?
एक पर्टिकुलर फाइल्स एंड डायरेक्टरीज को
सर्च करने का कमांड होता है। कोई फाइल्स
को सर्च करनी है, किसी डायरेक्टरी को सर्च
करनी है, तो आप फाइंड कमांड से सर्च कर
सकते हो। ठीक है? दैट्स इट। तो इसके लिए
एक कमा इसके लिए अलग-अलग सिंटेक्स होते
हैं। फाइंड उसके बाद जो भी पाथ पे आप सर्च
करना चाहते हो, व्हाटएवर पाथ यू वांट टू
सर्च। उसके बाद यहां पे हफन नेम और फाइल
का जो नाम है वो दे दीजिए। वो आप सर्च कर
सकते हैं। जैसे अगर मैं देता हूं यहां पे
फाइंड एंड यहां पे मैं पाथ देता हूं। तो
मुझे अगर मान लो dfon.xt खोजना है सश रूट
डेस्कटॉप पर यह फाइल खोजनी है। तो हफन नेम
कौन सा नाम है फाइल का? तो डेfronic.txt
मैं इस तरीके से दे देता हूं। तो ये मुझे
खोज के दे देगा। अगर मैं ऐसे ना भी दूं
डेस्कटॉप स्लैश रूट के बाद डेस्कटॉप भी ना
करूं। मैं सिर्फ रूट ही रहने दूं या स्लैश
ही रहने दूं तो भी ये काम हो जाएगा। स्लैश
मैं स्लैश में ही खोज लूं क्योंकि स्लैश
में ही रूट होता है। रूट में ही डेस्कटॉप
होता है। और मैं एंटर करूंगा तो ये खोजेगा
तो ये टाइम लगाएगा। अब ये पूरे स्लैश को
खोज रहा है। तो अब इसने खोज के निकाला रूट
डेस्कटॉप डिफरेंट. जो है इस लोकेशन पे
अवेलेबल है। तो ये होती है कि मल्टीपल
फाइल्स को आपको खोजनी है। तो आप खोज सकते
हैं इस पर्टिकुलर कमांड के थ्रू। काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग कमांड होती है। स्लैश के अंदर
ही पूरी लinक्स में देखो इसमें वैसे क्या
होता है कि लinक्स के अंदर में स्लैश के
अंदर ही सब कुछ होता है।
ठीक है? स्लश के अंदर ही सब कुछ होता है।
भाई एजोर ट्रोन ऑनलाइन यह आपके लिए तो
बिल्कुल बताया नहीं जा रहा है। आप बिल्कुल
आपके लिए अ नहीं है जो एडवांस यूजर अगर
कोई है तो इट्स नॉट नीडेड फॉर देम क्योंकि
इसका रीज़न यह है कि आप जो भी कमांड आप जो
भी आप यूज़ करते हैं ना Linux के अंदर में
चाहे आप जी पार्टीड यूज़ करें। ठीक है?
चाहे आप किसी भी तरह का पार्टीशन बनाएं
कुछ भी यूज़ करें। उन सबका बेस यही है जो
मैं आपको बता रहा हूं। एवरीथिंग स्टार्टेड
फ्रॉम दीज़ बेस दीज़ बेसिक्स एंड देन जाके
हम एडवांस हुए। यह बेसिक्स ही अगर किसी
न्यू कमर को बिगिनर को नहीं पता होगी ना
तो वो कुछ नहीं कर पाएगा। उसको आगे कुछ
समझ में नहीं आएगा। वो बस टूल यूज़ करेगा
एंड बस दैट्स इट। उसकी कहानी वहीं पे
समाप्त हो जाएगी। क्योंकि टूल यूज़ करना और
उसके कांसेप्ट को समझना दोनों में बहुत
डिफरेंस है। दैट्स व्हाई दीज़ आर वेरीेंट।
अब ये फाइंड कमांड बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग कमांड
होता है क्योंकि ये आपको पूरे स्लैश में
जो है ना पूरे स्लैश में वो आपको खोज के
चीजों को ला के देता है।
ठीक है? पूरे स्लैश के अंदर अब दिस इज़ द
ब्यूटी ऑफ़ दिस फाइंड कमांड कि आपको कुछ भी
खोजना है ना वो खोजो इससे। स्लैश दे दिया
नया नेम दे दिया। अब तुम इसमें खोज दो।
डिफ़ॉइंस txt के अलावा तुम्हें खोजना है।
मान लो कोई एक फाइल है। लेट्स सपोज़ ईटीसी
के अंदर में सोर्सेस डॉट लिस्ट आती है। एक
फाइल सोर्सेस डॉट लिस्ट ये एक फाइल आती
है। खोजना है एंटर कर दो। अब ये तुम्हें
खोज के निकाल के दे देगा कि ये कहां पे है
भैया? ईटीसी के अंदर ऐप के अंदर सोर्सेस
डॉट लिस्ट। तुम्हें फाइल का नाम पता है या
थोड़ा बहुत थोड़ी बहुत चीजें पता है वो
निकाल के दे देगा। अब तुम सिर्फ अगर
सोर्सेस लिखते हो ऐसे सोर्सेस तो ये क्या
करेगा? सोर्सेज से रिलेटेड जितनी भी लाइक
लोकेशनेशंस हैं सोर्सेज वाली सिर्फ उन्हीं
को लिस्ट करेगा। ये स्पेसिफिक टू द नेम
होता है। सोर्सेस डॉट लिस्ट करोगे तो
सिर्फ उसको खोजेगा। सोर्सेस कर दिया तो
सोर्सेस से रिलेटेड जितनी चीजें होंगी वो
सब तुम्हें लाके यहां पे प्रोवाइड कर
देगा। अब यहां पे मैं नेम के आगे अगर लगा
दूं तो ये क्या करेगा? देखो कुछ भी नहीं।
क्योंकि इसने कोई भी हमने एक्सटेंशन यहां
पे प्रोवाइड किया। हमने कुछ भी फाइल नेम
नहीं दिया। अगर अगर मैं यहीं पे सेम चीज
अगर मैं एस्टेरिस्क लगा दूं यहां पे
एस्टेरिस्क डॉट आरb कुछ इस तरीके से लगा
दूं और मैं एंटर करूं तो जितने भी आरबी
वाले फाइल्स हैं वो सारे खोज के दे देगा
मुझे ये तो आप देख सकते हो क्योंकि
मेटास्प्लॉयड्स के जो भी आपके
मेटास्प्लॉयड के अंदर में जो अंदर में आप
देखोगे यहां पर ऊपर की तरफ मैं बढ़ता हूं।
लेट्स सपोज दिस वन
यह रूबी के फाइल्स एक्सटेंशनंस हैं। तो,
आपको रूबी वाले सारे यहां पर दिख रहे हैं।
रूबी के अंदर जितने भी रूबी के फाइल्स
हैं, वह सारे आपको यहां पे देखने को मिल
जाएंगे। अभी मैं आपको और भी चीजें दिखाता
हूं।
जितने भी एक्सप्लॉय डीवी के अंदर
एक्सप्लाइट्स रूबी में बने हुए हैं, जो
मेटास्प्लॉयड्स में हम यूज़ करते हैं, वह
सारे भी आपको दिख जाएंगे। सो इट मींस कि
जितने भी वाली चीजें हैं वो सारी चीजें
आपको फाइल करके फाइंड करके आपको दे देता
है। तो दिस इज़ द वेरी ब्यूटीफुल कमांड
फाइंड कमांड।
ठीक है? उसी तरह से डीयू कमांड ये
डायरेक्टरी साइज यूसेज बताता है।
डायरेक्टरी की साइज यूसेज ये सब बताता है।
तो ये एक कमांड होती है। तो देयर आर
मल्टीपल कमांड्स जो यहां पे यूज़ में आते
हैं। सबसे पहले यहां पे अह टिप्स फॉर
एसओसी एज़ एन एसओसी आपके लिए कुछ टिप्स मैं
देना चाहूंगा। वो क्या है? ऑलवेज चेक
लॉग्स फर्स्ट स्लश वेयर स्लैश लॉग जो
लोकेशन है इसके लॉग्स को हमेशा आप चेक
कीजिए। यह काफी इंपॉर्टेंट होते हैं। यहां
पे आपको लॉग्स देखने को मिलते हैं। यूज़
ग्रिप प्लस टेल हफन एफ फॉर क्विक लॉग
इन्वेस्टिगेशन। ग्रिप कमांड का यूज़ कीजिए
और टेल कमांड का यूज़ कीजिए। इससे क्या
होता है? बेसिकली आप लॉग इन्वेस्टिगेशन
क्विकली कर सकते हैं। कंबाइन पीएस प्लस
नेट स्टैट टू फाइंड सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी।
आप सस्पिस एक्टिविटी को अ फाइंड करना है
तो पीएस और नेट स्टैट को यूज़ कर लीजिए।
प्रोसेससेस की लिस्ट देखिए। नेटस्टैट
नेटवर्क कनेक्शंस को देखिए। कौन से
नेटवर्क कनेक्शंस एक्टिव हैं उसे आप पता
लगा सकते हैं। रिसोर्स यूज़ज टॉप कमांड के
यूज़ कीजिए। रिसोर्स यूज़ज़ देखिए कि कौन से
रिसोर्स सबसे ज्यादा यूज़ हो रहे हैं। कुछ
हाईली बहुत ही ज्यादा तो यूज़ नहीं हो रहे
हैं। कोई रिसोर्स उस पे आपको डाउट जाना
चाहिए। बीइंग एन एसओसी L1 ऑलवेज वैलिडेट
बिफोर मेकिंग चेंज। हमेशा वैलिडेट कीजिए।
डॉक्यूमेंट फाइंडिंग्स एंड एस्केलेट इफ़
नीडेड। हर फाइंडिंग्स को डॉक्यूमेंट कीजिए
और मतलब कि लॉग उसका एक बैकअप एक
डॉक्यूमेंटेशन रखिए और अगर जरूरत पड़ी तो
उसको एस्केलेट कीजिए। कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट फाइल
जो लॉग पाथ्स होते हैं आपके एसओसी के लिए
वो है वायर log के अंदर सारे वायर लॉग के
अंदर ही आपको मिलेंगे। ऑथ डॉट log s लॉग
कर डॉट log dpkg डॉट log सिक्योर मैसेजेस
apache टू एनजिंग्स ये सब कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट
लॉग्स हैं जैसे ऑथेंटिकेशन लॉक्स सिस्टम
लॉक्स हैं कर्नल लॉक्स हैं पैकेज इंस्टॉल
लॉक्स हैं आरएचएल या सेंटs के ऑथ लॉक्स
यहां पे सिक्योर के अंदर में रहते हैं।
जनरल सिस्टम लॉक्स यहां होते हैं। अपाचे
लॉक्स अपाचे टू में होते हैं। इंजिंग्स
वेब सर्वर्स के लॉक्स उसके अंदर में होते
हैं। सो दीज़ कमांड्स आर योर फर्स्ट लाइन
ऑफ़ डिफेंस। यूज़ देम टुगेदर टू डिटेक्ट
इन्वेस्टिगेट एंड रिस्पॉन्ड टू सिक्योरिटी
इंसिडेंस इफेक्टिवली। प्रैक्टिस रेगुलरली
स्पीड कम्स विथ एक्सपीरियंस। दिस इज़ द
मोस्ट इंटरेस्टिंग एंड मोस्ट ऑथेंटिक लाइन
कि स्पीड कम्स विथ एक्सपीरियंस एंड
एक्सपीरियंस कम्स विद प्रैक्टिस। सो यू
नीड टू प्रैक्टिस एवरीडे यू नीड टू
प्रैक्टिस ऑल द टाइम टू मास्टर दीज़
कमांड्स टू अंडरस्टैंड दिस कमांड्स टू
प्रैक्टिस एंड टू प्रैक्टिस दीज़ आपको अपना
सिस्टम फायर अप करना है। Linux इंस्टॉलेशन
करनी है। कोई सी भी काली इंस्टॉल कर लो या
U ह्यूबन कर लो। कोई सी भी Linux उठाना
है। डाल देना है। और एक और ये जो चीजें
हैं प्रैक्टिस करनी आपको शुरू कर देनी है।
बस इतना ही तो करना है और तो कुछ भी नहीं
करना है। दैट्स इट। सो दैट्स इट फॉर टुडे
सेशन गाइस। आई होप कि आपको मजा आ गया
होगा। इसी के साथ लinक्स की जो हमारी यह
पार्ट है वह कंप्लीट होती है। लinक्स यहां
पे समाप्त होता है हमारा फॉर एसओसी और अब
हम नेक्स्ट क्लासेस से एसओसी के
प्रैक्टिकल डेमोंस्ट्रेशन लैब्स सीटीएफ्स
एंड मल्टीपल थिंग्स जो हम एसओसी को आगे ले
जाने के लिए करने वाले हैं वो स्टार्ट कर
देंगे। एंड एंड आई होप कि आपको मजा उसमें
भी मजा आएगा काफी क्योंकि उसका वेट काफी
टाइम काफी टाइम से काफी लोग कर रहे थे।
मुझे ऐसा लग रहा था। राइट? बट ये वीडियो
जो मैंने आपको बताया वो प्लीज देख लीजिएगा
टेक्निकल नेविगेटर YouTube चैनल पे आके
काली लinिक्स के प्लेलिस्ट में व्यू फुल
प्लेलिस्ट करके पार्ट वन से लेके पार्ट
सिक्स तक के वीडियोस कमांड्स को स्ट्रांग
करने के लिए देखिएगा इन कमांड्स को
प्रैक्टिस कीजिएगा और खुद से भी परफॉर्म
करके देखिएगा यू विल बी लविंग इट एंड आप
जितना प्रैक्टिस करेंगे कमांड्स को उतनी
अच्छी प्रैक्टिस हो जाती है उतना ज्यादा
आपके दिमाग में वो बैठेगा और उतना ही
ज्यादा अच्छा यूज़ आप उसको कर पाएंगे
बीइंग एन एसओसी एल1 राइट
ठीक है।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ओके। आई होप यू अंडरस्टैंड राइट।
थैंक यू सर। दिस क्लास अब अच्छे सब सच में
समझ आ रहे हो। थैंक यू। चलिए अच्छी बात
है। दैट ग्लैड ग्लैड।
ओके।
आई होप यू अंडरस्टुड राइट आई होप आप सब
समझ में आप सबको आ गया होगा। आई होप कि
आपको आज की सेशन आपको समझ में आई होगी।
आपकी आपको एग्जैक्ट
चीजें सारी चीजें क्लियर हुई होंगी। सो
मुझे एक बार सभी लोग बता दीजिए। एवरीथिंग
इज क्लियर। फाइन।
नेक्स्ट क्लासेस के लिए रेडी हैं आप?
क्योंकि हम नेक्स्ट क्लासेस से ही एसओसी
के खात्मे की तरफ बढ़ेंगे। एसओसी इस
ट्रेनिंग सेशन ट्रेनिंग के दी एंड की तरफ
बढ़ेंगे। लगभग अभी 24 फोर्थ क्लास चल रहा
है। आई थिंक 30 क्लासेस तक आपकी एसओसी हो
जानी चाहिए। 30 या 32 क्लासेस तक। जहां तक
मुझे लग रहा है खत्म हो जानी चाहिए। एंड
यह पूरी सीरीज कंप्लीट हो जानी चाहिए।
आपको शायद मजा भी आना चाहिए क्योंकि काफी
काफी लंबी-लंबी ये सीरीज चली है। दो-द
घंटे चली हैं यह क्लासेस। तो अगर मैं 30
क्लासेस की भी बात करूं तो 60 घंटे से भी
ऊपर की क्लासेस यह चली हैं। एंड 60 घंटे
से ऊपर की हमारी ही रिकॉर्डिंग रिकॉर्डेड
कोर्स है डीसीजीएसपी। उसके लिए हम 2500
जो है चार्ज करते हैं। यहां आपको फ्री में
मिल रहा है। एंड वह भी लाइव मिल रहा है।
इससे ज्यादा क्या मैं बोलूं?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
इंटरव्यू प्रिपरेशन वाली शायद अलग होगी।
उस 30 में तो नहीं आ पाएगी।
इस चीज को रिवाइज भी कीजिएगा। जब भी आप
वीडियो के रिकॉर्डिंग वीडियोस देखें तो
नीचे में हाइप का बटन आता है। हाइप पे
क्लिक कर दिया कीजिएगा। पॉइंट्स मिलते
हैं। उससे YouTube रिकमेंड करता है
वीडियोस को। वीडियो को शेयर जरूर कीजिएगा
सभी के साथ। जितने भी आपके एसओसी
एंथोजियास्ट हैं जो एसओसी में कुछ करना
चाहते हैं फ्री में उनको कंटेंट नहीं मिल
पा रहा है। सीख नहीं पाते हैं। आपको मैंने
दिखाया ही था हमारे WhatsApp चैनल पे कि
लोग ऐसे ही कंटेंट्स का एसओसी एल1
ट्रेनिंग का ₹-5000 चार्ज कर रहे हैं। आप
में से कई लोगों ने देखा होगा हमने पोस्ट
किया था हमारे WhatsApp चैनल के ऊपर में
₹5,000 चार्ज कर रहे हैं इस पर्टिकुलर
ट्रेनिंग के लिए। आपको यहां फ्री में मिल
रहा है और वहीं पर कुछ लोग जाकर 5000 देकर
वह पढ़ते हैं। फ्री में नहीं आ पाते हैं।
तो दिस इज द थिंग दैट फ्री में मिल चीज
मिली हुई चीजों का वैल्यू नहीं होता। यह
इसको प्रूफ तो करता है बट स्टिल जितने लोग
यहां प्रेजेंट हैं मैं उनके लिए काम कर
रहा हूं। मैं उनके लिए सोच रहा हूं कि
एटलीस्ट वो तो इस चीज को पढ़ लें। एंड वो
कुछ अच्छा कर ले लाइफ में। अगर उनमें से
आप में से 50 लोगों में से 50 के 50 25 20
10 लोग भी अगर कुछ अच्छा कर पाते हैं तो
मुझे जो खुशी होगी वह नेक्स्ट लेवल की
होगी। बस यही मैं चाहता हूं। तो दैट्स इट।
प्लीज कंटिन्यू द सीरीज एंड एंड तक रहिए।
जब यहां तक आप आ चुके हैं। यहां तक आप रह
चुके हैं तो लास्ट तक भी रहिएगा आप। ठीक
है?
प्लीज सर बताइए सर एसओसी एल1 के लिए
डिप्लोमा इन सीएससी करना हो वर्थ इट होगा।
डिप्लोमाप्लोमा तो करो ही मत। तो उसका कोई
वैल्यू नहीं है। पहले ही मैं बता रहा हूं।
डिप्लोमा कोर्सेज और डिप्लोमा ये सब चीजें
मत करो। करना है सीधा सिंपल सा आप यार
बीसीए, बीटेक ओटेक कर लो। डायरेक्ट
ग्रेजुएशन टाइप चीजें करो। ये
डिप्लोमाप्लोमा क्या होती है यार? ये सब
फालतू की चीजें हैं। मत करो कोई फायदा
नहीं है।
ओके
या
सर मैंने एक प्रोग्राम की मैंने साइट पर
मैंने hटीएमएल बग रिपोर्ट किया था।
उन्होंने नॉट इन स्कोप कह के। हां, तो कोई
बात नहीं। नॉट इन स्कोप करके रिजेक्ट कर
दिया। तो उसमें तुम क्या कर सकते हो? कुछ
नहीं कर सकते। कोई भी अगर प्रोग्राम पेज
हंट कर रहे हो। तो यह उनके ऊपर है कि
तुम्हारी वह बग को एक्सेप्ट कर रहे हैं कि
नहीं कर रहे हैं। अगर कोई बहुत हाई
इंपैक्ट वनेबिलिटी है। अगर हाई इंपैक्ट
दिखा सकते हो तो हमेशा कोशिश करो कि बहुत
अच्छा इंपैक्ट दिखा के ही रिपोर्ट करें।
अदरवाइज रिपोर्ट ना करें। नहीं तो वो उसको
कैसे भी क्लोज कर सकते हो। उसमें तुम कुछ
नहीं कर सकते। कई ऐसी कंपनीज़ तो बहुत सारी
ऐसी कंपनीज़ फ्रॉड भी करती हैं कि हाई
इंपैक्ट वनेबिलिटी रिपोर्ट करोगे। वो उसको
रिज़ॉल्व भी कर लेंगे और तुम्हें क्रेडिट
भी नहीं देंगे। तुम्हें बोलेंगे उनको वो
बोलेंगे कि नहीं यह तो ऑलरेडी रिॉल्व था
या ऐसीबिटी एक्सिस्ट नहीं करती थी या हम
हमें ऑलरेडी पता था या आपका डुप्लीकेट है
ऐसा भी होता है तो जस्ट डोंट गिव टाइम ऑन
दोज़ प्लेटफॉर्म्स और ऑन दोज़ प्रोग्राम्स
लीव इट मूव टू द नेक्स्ट बेटर प्रोग्राम्स
ठीक है उसमें आप कुछ नहीं कर सकते
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यस बीटेक कर लो बहुत अच्छी बात रहेगी
बीटेक या बीसीए कोई से भी कर लो ओके गाइस
सो दैट्स इट फॉर टुडे सेशन आई होप यू
एंजॉयड द सेशन एंड एंड हम मिलते हैं
नेक्स्ट सेशन में एसओसी के क्लासेस को।
यहां टॉप फैंस के लिस्ट मैं आपको दिखा
देता हूं। दिस इज़ आर द टॉप फैंस लिस्ट जो
यहां पे आपको देखने को मिल रहा है। एज
यूजुअल सिमिलर नेम्स आई एम सीइंग हियर इन
द लिस्ट जो जनरली मैं हमेशा देखता ही हूं।
कुछ-कुछ इसमें नए नाम दिख रहे हैं। अच्छी
बात है। अगर दिख रहे हैं, दैट्स गुड। एंड
दीज़ आर द नेम्स दोज़ आर प्रेजेंट रेगुलरली
टिल द एंड। टिल द एंड यह लोग रहते हैं। तो
इट्स ग्रेट टू सी राइट। चलिए तो आज के
सेशन को यहां कंप्लीट करते हैं। जाने से
पहले वही काम कर लीजिएगा जो काम आप करते
हैं हमेशा लाइक ठोकते हुए चले जाइएगा
क्योंकि अभी 77 लाइक्स हैं। 100 प्लस करके
ही आपको जाना है सभी को। तो लाइक ठोकते
चले जाइएगा। सब्सक्राइब कर लीजिएगा। नहीं
किया होगा सब्सक्राइब तो सिंपल सा फंडा
है। बहुत सिंपल सा तरीका है। सिंपल सा
तरीका है। बस सब्सक्राइब बटन दबाना है और
काम खत्म। बेल आइकॉन को प्रेस कर लीजिएगा।
नोटिफिकेशन मिलती रहेगी। शेयर कीजिएगा
वीडियोस को जितने शेयर कर सकते हैं। यही
हमारा सपोर्ट है। यही हमारा आप जो प्यार
है आपकी तरफ से वह मिलता है। सब जितना आप
शेयर करेंगे वीडियोस पहुंचेगी और उन लोगों
तक जाएगी जो लोग एक्चुअली इसको डिर्व करते
हैं। एक्चुअली सीखना चाहते हैं। राइट? सो
दैट्स इट फॉर टुडेेस सेशन गाइस। थैंक यू
वेरी मच एवरीबॉडी। मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट
क्लास में। बाय-ब टेक केयर। गुड नाइट। शुभ
रात्रि।